[Music]
this is nice yeah we don't do this
enough
i know we used to do this all the time
remember god it's just nice to get out
of that house
[Music]
no no no no no we're just here geez
this happens all the time i know i know
non-stop probably because
someone had to show up in full skeleton
makeup that's not fair you guys used to
do the same thing
yeah 120 years ago it was a fashion
thing back then it was different people
were doing the skeleton look yeah 700
a.d called they want you to uh get a new
thing
hey guys what do you think about doing
uh matching cloaks
oh that'd be fun yeah like a club yeah i
can make patches see how we like them
just make sure it's not a three-piece
rocker
anyone thinking we're in a gang yeah
that won't help at all freaking
crusaders had to ruin that one for the
rest of us
oh that ship sailed a while ago hey no
don't panic we're we're just here to get
you can't you can't talk with these
people get used to it new normals here
guys
maybe for you
what does that mean yeah what does that
mean here we go all i'm saying
at a certain point what you get is it
worth what you do okay
come on we all had to make changes not
this [ __ ] again
look forget about it forget i said
anything
you don't think it's because we have
hell following with a studio
doesn't help
[Music]
you're staying that's what i
[Music]
know
oh yes yeah i can't do any thrusting
because i hurt my back
don't blame the two blame the two people
of color next to me the hodge twins
conservative twins how are you gents
we're doing great what do
by the way the hashtag is a crowder dnc
stream we'll be streaming all night
we'll be taking some of your tweets
there's a promo code
crowd or dnc stream you get 20 dollars
off
club lotto.com
it's a pretty good deal we're
redistributing what is that
that looks like a james cromwell
character
gone wrong that's just like they said
let's put let's put a guy who's
sunburned
and pockmarked on air because he has
rivers cuomo glasses
all right uh we also uh we'll be uh
going through uh the entire
lineup tonight we were planning on doing
this for the whole week yeah
and then we realized that you know we
didn't want to
that was about it it was a death wish i
mean there was there was no way i was
going to let you do it oh my half asian
lawyer bill richmond by the way
there's half asian lawyer richmond who
refused to dress in 80s garb it's 80s
night best 80s costume
wins what do they win i mean they win
stuff they win a lot they win all
those in a box they win a lock of post
rehab uh michael jackson's hair over
here
i thought he's tito i gained a little
bit of weight
looks good cheeto to jermaine yeah uh
and then we have a cute maddie and
overlays too cute maddie she makes me
sick
and we have audio wade here um really i
guess the question of the day is um
why why are we doing this why is anyone
tuning into this at this point we
we're planning on doing it all week
because we didn't think that they would
announce the vp candidate and then when
they announced
harris we said okay well we don't need
to watch anyone else because
no one cares right but then i looked at
tonight's lineup and it's like a who's
who of nobody cares
tammy baldwin who is that tammy
ducksworth
can you read this one because it's going
to be more like who's that oh chris
coons that's for the auto sensor on
youtube
right uh andrew yang michael bloomberg
do you think andrew yang like do you
think right before he walks out on stage
you're just gonna have to take the
barrel of the gun out of his mouth
just a minute sir just a minute think
about this first andrew yang if you guys
have seen
the screenshots where he just responded
to people on instagram although i can't
believe it's biden he's like i know
me either it's like you endorsed it
right yeah
disappointed disappointed under i
understand and know the feeling
and then they dropped him out just
because they needed an asian who didn't
come across as aggressive
like andrew yang you come out here you
don't seem uh you know
you're you seem like friendly like you
know you drink and you swear
they'll get the kids right along with
cardi b all right singing about her wet
vagina and then interviewing the
potential president of the united states
yang's just going to our bud dwyer this
thing it's going to be rough
i'd rather be watching cuties
i don't know you know the things with
cute maybe bill clinton
yeah yeah who's who also uh spoke
earlier with the dnc
talk about a who it's a who's who if
nobody cares the character also
who's who have registered sex offenders
that's the dnc right now we have gavin
newsom right here
and we'll talk about him later this is
the guy who was praising donald trump's
handling of coronavirus until he went
you know he went the other way because
there was a convention coming up and
this is a guy who obviously complained
about he complained about violent
protests
back in the uh uh i believe uh maybe it
was like 2016.
about the right wingers we can bring
that up he's talking about right-wing
violence and how it's not funny and we
can't spur it
no condemnation of his entire city being
torn apart
nope everybody's constituents are are
leaving in droves
and who would have thought that from
lost who would have thought that a
sequel with kurt russell it would be
real it would be like looking into a
crystal ball
yeah what do you guys expect for tonight
uh conservative twins by the way is uh
who they are
yeah a bunch of liars lying yeah
hypocrisy i mean jesus what's next for
these people
i mean anything they say man it doesn't
surprise me all right well i'm going to
go through a list and you tell me what
you guys think uh and you folks can tell
me what you think uh we have by the way
andrew clavin on the show that's true
oh i forgot the drinking game rules the
drinking game rules that's really
important
drinking game rules anytime biden
stutters you have to take a drink
no if you hear uh any reference to him
by the way it's not an exact
verbiage black lives matter fascist
fascism racist
ism anything about the us postal service
uh really any failing non-business and
uh coronavirus
coronavirus wait so are the rules that
we drink every time he stutters on a
single word because i've seen him
stutter like nine times just getting
a past participle out i mean yeah i
don't it doesn't it doesn't count if
he's stuttering over the same vomit
choke
okay i just wanted to if he's
continually aspirating his own vomit
it just counts as one stop okay okay it
counts as one stutter look don't invite
a lawyer if you don't want to get the
rules no no i understand i appreciate
the rules
that's what happened to me when i heard
about cuties cuties
for those who don't know on netflix can
we bring up an over cuties is a show
about like nine-year-olds twerking
we're gonna get to the dnc here's our
prediction but oh wait hold on so let's
go to cnn really quickly because they're
they're saying that uh this is coming up
i shouldn't be talking about
here i hope the virus is in check and
the american spirit
is unleashed and that we're when did he
take
him but i hope the virus is in check
there's a time capsule his senior year
hello mr beacham uh i hope the virus no
longer exists
three months from now hope you never
changed did he not take this today
i believe that america will have faced
its darkest moment and will have come
out better
she's talking about
[Music]
english lady
who provides this country with real
leaders they just brought him on because
they were hoping it would trick people
to thinking he was in the roosevelt
bloodline
yeah teddy or one of you know one of
them
i hope we all get back to work they'll
be choosing yes
that was my korean cousin this time next
week oh god oh come on hey that's where
the white women are wishing they were
candidates yeah that's where the white
women aren't the mushroom cuts are us
we'll be proud do you think she went in
and said like hey could you make it look
like i have half a bean bag on my chair
where's this nick at founder andrew yang
founder humanity forward
they don't say former presidential
candidate
to this demented old circus monkey you
will be watching today
like former's former senator united
states tattoo artist
she's hot for man she met once
the rights well that's what i'm talking
about right here this time next year
i want a president who understands what
military families need
who cares crazy rights oh come on um
what is who is she let's let's be
careful
[Applause]
[Music]
but
[Music]
this time next year he's been sneaking
into people's houses
stealing gum guns and leaving crumbs
that are much too small
for the house's mouth yeah
we have that you have the ding for the
uh for the drinking game we'll get it
pulled off all right they said
coronavirus
drink are you going to be doing the
dinner all night
i don't have the day okay okay what
i can write oh no colin powell
you guys are new to this oh no jamie
harrison whoever the right guys are new
to the republican
actually condoleezza rice kind of came
out and said like you guys are just a
bunch of [ __ ]
you guys just yeah but oh no hey look
it's her
it's medusa i'm
african-american all right quick
predictions what do you guys expect for
tonight uh
i think we're just going to see a lot of
not very many clear policy answers i
think we can expect
to oh my god they're opening with yang
right away what's he saying
is he opening in prayer no in the future
national anthem no
pledge of allegiance no american flag
pin no it says math
it's like hmm i don't want to be i don't
it seems like it's a little cliche
to have you know running for national
office representing your country flag
pin
can i go with math with the last name
yang can i do that that's safe
also maybe maybe the other lapel could
be an image of my
tiger mom beating me i think that this
would be palatable to middle america i
think this is going to go over well
because the flag pins are passed
if you voted for trump or didn't vote at
all back in 2016.
i get it many of us have gotten tired of
our leaders seeming far more
from our everyday lives we despair that
our government will ever rise to the
challenges of our time
oh the challenge the challenges of our
time before the covet like
record low unemployment like record low
black unemployment like
record high labor force participation
gdp growth
all-time stock market highs like actual
wage growth for middle class americans i
think was about five thousand dollars a
year more americans who are paying less
in taxes and more satisfied with their
economic outlook than ever
please lord jesus save us from this
bring us your prophet
wang yang it would have been great too
if i didn't get his name wrong but it's
almost better
yeah it's coming up why they got steph
curry coming steph curry that's not on
this lineup
looks like you know what it looks like
they bumped pete butt gig for steph
curry the book
yeah so i don't think we're going to see
any clear policy answers tonight i think
we're just going to hear a lot of
platitudes we're going to hear about how
bad donald trump is
please save us from our darkest hour
yeah john legend noted profiles noted
you genesis
john legend he'll be on the show uh all
right let me see let's see uh you guys
know pete butterjudge you guys know
what who got what do you predict
anything
all right let me move on what about uh
gavin newsom no hey
keisha lance bottoms that's in your
right up that's in your wheelhouse yep
bottoms
up tammy baldwin ducksworth
anyone have strong opinions ducksworth
who the hell is tammy duckworth
that's what i thought she's the asian i
don't know i thought maybe you get like
a stripper
senator chris coons yeah i like coons
i see where this is performance by john
legend
and common oh no performance who's
almost worse is common the guy who looks
like tyra banks his brother but isn't
tyra banks his brother that guy i think
yeah
yeah yeah he's bald right yeah he's got
like light eyes
yeah he's got dark ass he's got dark
eyes i'm thinking of tyra banks his
brother the guy who wasn't dodgeball
which i know listen i know it sounds
tone deaf
in large part because it is uh i've
always said this like you guys have
lighter eyes but when i see when i meet
really
like darker black guys you know with
light eyes um
it scares me you're racist
the you know the queen of the damned
film you know
vampires or blades which you know what
was that aliyah
when she died we all had to act like a
marvelous talent like we have to do with
cardi b and just she was just
waiting our way through her talking
about her wet vagina and cutting her
[ __ ] with her freddy krueger nails
i'm like oh i can't believe we lost
cardi b
to diabetes of all things who knew two
anal fissures
well i'd probably think eight was an
infection yeah that's what you started
talking about the cardi b interviewed
our president of the united remember we
thought
it was below the presidency when that uh
what was his name in that what was the
name of that uh that that that
that black broad who was in the in that
black brother
in the tub with the fruit loops she had
like green hair oh
um she does reaction videos on youtube
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah well she did you
know you know and then the novelty wore
off and then
barack obama did an interview with other
people thought it was below the
presidency yeah yeah
now we have the potential president
talking with a lady who's
forgive me forgive my language this is
pg we have to talk about who's like yo
yo my [ __ ] can't believe in these genes
you want me to get a yeast infection
i gotta go interview the vice president
the same woman who said she bragged
about drugging and robbing me
yeah that's right i i drug men and
robbed them
now i'm gonna go interview the president
what about healthcare though
[Laughter]
you you wanna see me get triggered just
have someone go
wait is that like a bird in an oil spill
what does that represent
i don't know what the hell she does when
she does that i don't know what the hell
it is that sounds like those those like
when the pigeons were in the bp
like yeah yeah they're walking down with
dawn and we're supposed to care i think
it's like a tick
is it i think so is that what it sounds
like
right and you just can't control it all
right let's go uh to julia louis-dreyfus
uh
are you guys familiar with seinfeld i
don't know yeah okay good i don't know
if i'd like you're more
30330 is that's the year
donald trump will finally release his
tax returns
oh give the [ __ ] about tax returns
nothing
looks like the lady performer hired a
lady writer
don't let him near a comedy pen let's
reaffirm
the all-american values that our party
and jokes like abortions into nine
months jim crow
the kkk
i pledge allegiance to the flag
of the united states of america into a
public
but which is this he's a cute kid
hey it's my cousin i'm glad they're
doing this
and justin are you remembering
a flag pin they're like that's cute
you're patriotic if you did this in a
few years we'd call you a race trainer
but for now it's the coal novelty
hey look it's the chicks soon to be the
z's
yeah i'm not convinced they're drunk
you know that right yeah they dropped
dixie chicks because they thought that
was racially insensitive so they became
the chicks and of course you're going to
change it to the z's it's like when lady
antebellum dropped it to lady a and then
this black chick was like
that's my name though and they were like
we didn't know
also i'm gonna sue you yeah all right
hold on a second let's listen to the i
always feel bad because
the one with the lesbian cut is the most
talented but you know everyone looks at
the
the sisters
nice i thought they could sing a lot
better than this
i think they're pretty good i don't know
that is nice
i think they're talented they just hate
the country
[Music]
what does nick cannon have to say now
very little melanin
they got soul unfortunately you know i
mean it's accurate uh
yeah but they have so it's dark
[Music]
[Applause]
let's do some soul in that
[Applause]
was that after cnn probably singing
[Applause]
lovely looking ladies to the guy who
looks like beans from even stephen
hey actually reg does have an answer to
what skrt means
if you want to go oh yeah let's go to
reg the bandit our brilliant researcher
in uh in chief reg what does bra mean
do we have them okay so to the best of
my understanding
is an onomatopoeia used in the
african-american community
okay and it signifies moving away from
someone quickly
or did sustain yourself and it's like
the skidding of tires in a car
oh okay here we go so it's it's
tied to felonies okay
this is one thing that really does that
really does okay so let's go through
predictions here andrew yang michael
bloomberg
says suck suck suck suck no one cares
it's uh crowder dance
stream for twenty dollars off and uh
hashtag credit dnc stream for the uh the
hashtag are we gonna be able to see
reggie there range the band yeah pretty
soon
um we were talking about this earlier
today right you have cardi b
who uh just interviewed the vice
president i do feel bad for
young black women because like that is
their
a big part of their their role models
right now is nicki minaj and that wasn't
always the case when people say like oh
this is black culture
what about diana ross yeah you go back
to the supremes you go back to
aretha franklin you go you go back to
the the cosby show you go back to
like family matters uh fresh prince of
bel air
the cosby show these were by and large
watched by white people it wasn't
segmented away on its own network that
tyler perry bought and sold to oprah
right that's why those shows were so
important the cosby show was good for
black people to see other successful
black people yeah you got cardi b
i mean it's better they didn't see the
green room
too bad bill cosby was a creep yeah yeah
that's really unfortunate yeah you know
we talked about this before we were
talking about the hidden figures movie
right i mean you got you got
what movie the hidden figures movie with
the late the the mathematicians
the black women who were helping nasa oh
hidden figures i said invigorating i
don't know hidden figures and so think
about it you had all of these women who
were in that vein or who were actually
in
that and lived it and you could have had
them interviewing but instead yeah
well you know what's funny is like i bet
you in the future like those because
those ladies
were all uh very nice in that film but
they'll be like why is there an aquafina
and carly b
cardi b did i say carly typical white
white girl name i knew a girl named nick
harley she turned me down all right
let's go to david koshner's latest
character
oh it's glammy
people joe believes were made in the
image of god
joe learned that from his parents the
nuns and priests right here in delaware
who taught him
who revoked his communion privileges
wait wait were they the ones who taught
him to love segregation
yeah i know you taught him to love
segregation oppose bussing and support
abortion up to after birth i'm pretty
sure that came straight down from the
cardinals
i've known joe about 30 years and i've
seen his faith in action
joe knows the power everyone in dc has
known him 30 years
that's the problem he's been suckling at
the taxpayer's teeth his entire life
he has not been employed by the private
sector since he was old enough
to have a boner
sorry a guinea time and again i've seen
him
stop everything and listen really listen
to someone who needs it that's because
he can't hear them
again i've seen him change his phones
for those with the larger keypad because
he cares
really leans in yeah he leans again
i've seen him go to iowa state fairs and
travel to caucuses across this land with
his life alert bracelet
just to show how much he cares
where we have a more just immigration
policy and where we call out and
confront the original sins of this
nation
the sins of slavery
let it go i'm over it
once you guys are as punishment since
you didn't import the ding there uh uh
mj there you go
how are they gonna make slavery right
how are you gonna go back and change it
well you see how they're gonna change it
is uh is uh by electing
the oldest white guy who supported
segregation and said they're gonna put
you all back in shape
i i do appreciate that another six
another succeeding old white guy this
one doesn't even have hair
he's the one who's telling us about how
he's the one it's a receding guys don't
worry we're going to fix this
right after i finished my ninth senate
campaign
and i'm done with this and i don't give
it to my son it'll be fine it'll be
totally fine
yeah and the poor guy does happy i mean
just thing looks like it's made of damn
pipe cleaners
but you know he's got the hair plugs
going on there's nothing he did he did a
shitty job but the point is like you
know he's trying
what is your faith so how would you use
your faith
and make a decision for our nation
reverend uh oh he steps out from the
podium so i know he's serious now he's
getting serious
most people aren't i'm willing to get
down with you blacks
this is propaganda this is yeah oh my
gosh i love the music though my family
i came back can i drop a chair regular
service
because i just lost my son and obviously
that's sad
that's very tragic but that is what he
uses right now rather than discussing
the policies
does anyone know his coronavirus plan by
the way can anyone can reach me bring
that up i know he said he would double
testing we have more testing than any
country right now
in in the world right we have more
testing and donald trump uh mobilize the
private sector
like him or hate him to include to get
more testing right now you can go to cvs
walgreens rite aid dwayne reed if you
live in if you still live in the
cesspool
that filth and sadness and broken dreams
and hypodermic needles that is
new york city i highly recommend you
leave 14
000 empty apartments yeah escape from
l.a escape from new york
from right now yeah yes
yeah i was just going to say that you
know how much it takes to actually say
we're going to double it nothing it's
absolutely no commitment no it's just
like
yeah but i'll double it okay nice i want
you to take your asking price
and double it yes yes wow yeah that
sounds really good
because that's tw he's got a double
testing that's two times more than
than now that's two times as many
and i know because i saw andrew yang's
pin
i think if he becomes president they
would actually suppress the numbers
yeah of course i don't know it's just
like he doesn't have no does anyone know
any of his policies other than he really
likes abortion and hates donald trump
and he can't count to ten without unless
if he's wearing mittens
very very pro but he's a leader stephen
he's a he's a leader yeah he's a he's a
natural-born leader who's
followed in in the senate his entire
career
all right hold on let's see what uh she
looks good though
hello this is mary bottoms that's why i
thought you know maybe she'd be your gym
how are you feeling yeah
cheekbone action well good evening i
feel
really good thank you for asking my
husband on the other hand is still
having many of the lingering side
effects that people talk about but all
in all
our family is doing great we can't
breathe being married to you he's gonna
be boy i think
americans are going to be dealing with
that for a long time
hey mayor i wanted to ask you something
many of us will have a cost
atlanta ready for election day sometime
meaning a week yeah
a little bit of the sniffles we will be
do
they also not remember that they are the
network where chris cuomo was like
quarantined
yeah for three days and came out but
naked appearing nude yeah and his wife's
yoga video was like i'm totally fine now
my teeth were shattering i had a fever
of 106.00
is it oh hey julius that's some dog we
got weekend at bernie's joe lewis
hello joe lewis hello joe lewis
look at this guy look at this handsome
boy weekend at joe lewis's the hawaiian
shirt
go overs go say hi go say hi to the guys
who used to be afraid of you
please joe come on go say hi come on joe
hawaiian five oh
yeah hey guys you see the difference
this is what i was saying
when you have behaved dogs they can be
therapy dogs these guys were terrified
of them mostly because they were chasing
them when they were
delivering leaning all over me i know
yeah he loves you guys he's a leader
oh that stain's hard i know he did he he
narded one of you guys right in the with
his tail face of it
yeah he's got that giant tail that just
it hits you right in the tip just
oh yeah bye joe lewis okay let's go back
to mayor keisha bottoms and her husband
with the covid
john lewis he walked gently amongst us
not as a distant icon but as a
god-fearing
man who did what he could to fulfill
the as yet unfulfilled promise of
america
what what what people often think that
they can
be what i'm sorry speaking to my good
ear
i don't speak crazy [ __ ] unfulfilled
dream of the united states of america
she's mayor and she's speaking to
endorse the old white guy who played
second fiddle to the black guy with no
resume
who became president of the united
states she's a black she's black too
only in the united states could a man
with zero qualifications
the public having zero access to his
college records and a man who did crack
with a convicted domestic terrorist and
bill ayers
be elected president of the united
states but still the deck is stacked
against us
cardi b writes songs about cutting her
[ __ ] with freddy krueger hands
it's the american dream and she's
today's earth wind and fire
she's you're hauling out for crying out
loud no hell no she's holding oaks
don't don't touch my halls you set them
off
keep going don't dump myself
all right let's hear what she has to say
are disgracefully
using this pandemic to spread pandemic
drink
epidemic and interfere with voting
forcing many in 2020
to still risk their lives wait because
forcing tons of people to become more
dependent on the government
everybody else is walking around with
masks yeah you know what can we actually
do we have that uh let me see
we have uh the clip of uh because they
just said they just opened with you know
julia louis-dreyfus elaine saying we
need to trust the experts let's go to
clip c
because if you she talked about dr fauci
and now they're saying we don't want to
send people out into harm's way like
it's d-day and
like they're acting like you're going to
go to your local precinct
in freaking denton county and they're
going to open the doors and
like it's just there's nothing you just
just
you know what you don't even need to
wear a mask i do do it because you have
to it's the law
but the fact is you are not this is not
comparable
to fighting nazis not even okay
it's not even close let's go to the clip
c of dr fauci saying hey can we go and
vote in person
can people safely go out and vote in
person
given that this year there is so much uh
concern
around the vote i think if
carefully done according to the
guidelines
there's no reason that i can see why
that not be the case
and he's got two strings to hold him
down
i want to be a real boy for crying out
loud his voice
going to the gas station going to
gristor going to work they're wearing
masks but you can't show up at a damn
voting
right to vote with a mask imagine
leaving your house looking like dr fouch
you have any people you have idea how
many people want to kick his ass just
seeing him
no they can't see him it's just he keeps
showing these old ass videos
go it's over oh hold on a second they're
gonna bring out the german shepherds
wait who was
[Music]
life was extremely dangerous it was
that's right
it was i appreciate it they're reminding
us about
what joe biden furthered did you see
that guy stand from the office he said
it's worse now
and his kickstarter trying to start a
spin-off show like racism is worse now
than ever
really you've been fire hosed outside a
pie shop recently
stanley
john was focused on ending are they
really trying to show this and like
equate it to now
and they'll avoid like the plague that
john lewis claimed when he was walking
through
the uh the uh i believe it was was it
the walking to the house
i don't know if he was walking on the
capitol steps him and clyburn if i'm not
mistaken
said that people spat on them tea
partiers you know those protesters spat
on them and called them the n-word
andrew breitbart offered a hundred
thousand dollars to the united negro
college fund i can say because that's
still the name of the fund
and there was no footage and here's what
matters there was footage of john lewis
of clyburn
walking up those steps there were
gigabytes
and gigabyte and this was before 4k
there were gigabytes and gigabytes
of crappy grainy 720p footage
where you could hear everything and see
everything every single
angle like we were promised with
original dvds remember they said you
could watch things in 360. that never
really did
once did anyone say the n word and the
media said well just like me with
nashville they said well
why doesn't i need to prove that because
someone called him the n-word uh because
he said it
because he made a claim how about that
if you make a point
if you make a claim of a hate crime have
some evidence of the hate crime
we're all listen obviously it's sad when
someone dies but let's not
lie about john lewis the guy was a race
baiter professionally for the rest of
his life
yeah brothers are here a long time
that's a bunch i can't stand maxine
waters man a kind of
heft a weightiness oh yeah maxine waters
sometimes she kind of looks like
like a photo-negative nancy pelosi the
black version
yeah the black version of nancy pelosi
like if i were to
if i were in a dark room developing
photos i might get it wrong
like label it pelosi it's like spy
versus spine
there we go someone who has navigated
oh why is she even relevant well they
should just have her lower third be
not vice president
i will graciously accept today we are
considering a fair housing measure
which not only protects our nation's
minorities
but it protects the needs of those with
disabilities
and families with children how long do
we have to wait
before we decide to ban assault weapons
we have enough by the way oh did you see
that by the way
ban assault weapons but it was a handgun
registrat was it handgun registration
act something handgun act
so keep in mind that back then they
weren't even trying to hide it like
assault weapons was a handgun
if you were to tell people now well an
assault weapon would be most of your
handguns for example any of the handguns
that people are carrying in here
americans were like whoa no no no i
thought you meant like
you know the ak-47 that that guy in
austin got killed for pointing at a car
point blank range
no back then it was they would say
assault weapons and handguns
interchangeably yeah
then they realized they had to get away
from it yeah weapons that hurt
all bad bad
all right here let me go through the
mail thing really quickly because they
were just talking about that
okay so um let's talk about the mail
when people are saying
keep in mind right off the right off the
bat most of the pictures out there are
hoaxes they're like look they're
destroying mailboxes
no they're actually trying to replace
mailboxes and there were changes coming
down the pike for the
for usps for a very long time you know
why for 13 years
in a row they've lost money 13 years
in a row they've lost money imagine
pitching that on shark tank
incredibly consistent what are your
numbers uh well we lost
18 trillion but this is like the first
yeah this is the first 13 years of the
company right yeah
right yeah you've been reinvesting in
inventory now well i mean
amazon did have you seen their new
amazon vans they really got their [ __ ]
together
fedex has next day shipping that's fun
but
uh we really could use some money well
what kind of money do you have uh well
uh i guess in a matter of speaking it's
it's really infinite really because we
can just take it from taxpayers yeah so
uh how we just lost all of our sign off
right now we've lost all of it and
haven't managed to turn a profit is
you know your guess is as good as mine
but um we could always use more
so mr o'leary more money please more
money please
[Laughter]
so all right let me make sure i have
this right so uh when people say there
hasn't been voter fraud too we talk
about
mail and i say this as someone who has
had to mail in vote uh because i've been
traveling doing comedy shows i think one
time i might have even been in canada
doing a stand-up show
um let's go through a couple of examples
new jersey they tried in the primaries
1.4 something million voters between 1.4
1.5
87 of them voted through mail it took
counties more than
six months to certify the election
results 65
000 ballots had to be thrown out
completely for right away
those are just the ones that we know
about that's called disenfranchised
michigan 846 battles just had to be
thrown out because the
voters were dead
uh exactly
[Applause]
great question why don't you ask that
captain obviously andrew yang is like
you do the math
they're dead again no it's common it's
common it is common it's the guy with
the uh
[Music]
for people who don't know the promo code
is crowder dnc
stream for twenty dollars off yeah
seem like they're stuck in the past
whenever they say anything yeah yeah
like not only in the past like 40 years
ago because it can't be stuck in the
recent past because that's
barack obama yeah sure
lucas the eugenics yeah exactly so this
guy called i i believe if i'm not
mistaken he actually called donald trump
we have an overlay i think he called
donald trump a eugenicist
and he's the guy who wanted to boycott
states that put restrictions on
abortions
past the third trimester dude he's an
actual he supports actual eugenicism
yeah trump's the most pro-life president
we ever had i know he called him a
eugenicist and that he campaigned
against
not only i mean that's wrong on so many
levels because the idea of free
enterprise
uh but because states wanted to put
limitations on abortion remember when it
was georgia that was that whole thing
he was leading the charge he's got is
something else by the way we see these
commercials on cnn we bring up that
image of the black guy who does a
commercial for the testosterone
new jetix it's a black guy doing an
ad for a supplement that's one letter
off of eugenics
he's like newgenix worked for me
before this i was black as hell
i've had some crazy is this it yes yeah
this oh hold on let me see
yeah look look new genix he's like a
former football player or best one yeah
oh look at that joe he actually works up
in the gym i go to really yeah
he actually he seems like a nice guy
that's a big dude man
he was sitting on a stationary bike
looking like a damn tricep
new jets oh that's horrible speaking of
which you're the byproduct of new jet of
eugenics there uh joe lewis they breed
you for hunting boar
i don't know why you're wearing a prison
outfit but uh go say go say hi go say hi
to keith and kevin okay no you want to
say hi to me
that's very nice you appreciate it he's
a pretty sweet
why does he have a shake he's got a
shake my wife gave my dog a shift
i guess she's trying to go with the
common theme uh all right time for you
go say hi and then go get out joe lewis
joe lewis come here joe loose there you
go i want to listen to comments
what are you doing down there joe
wait is this a praise and worship song
when the glory comes it will be
hours when the glory comes it will be
hours black is kingdom god is king joe
lewis
go come on you got to go to mama i do
have to ask a question because often
times you hear
well i was like i can't get over when
the glory comes it will be ours
they took the lyrics of praise and
worship like the glory will be yours god
it's like
who's glory commons yeah yeah they got
old choir their whole choir singing god
who's glory john legend
jesus it's jesus christ unbelievable
these people say these so religious but
they're pro-choice
oh they're wrong about everything and
also they they believe that the quote
the verse is give unto caesar
give it all to caesar yeah give it all
the seizure provided
you know that he has uh he that he
increases the size of the dmv and make
sure you don't change mailboxes that's
somewhere in mark were you about to say
something they're half asian
i was going to say the idea of if you
were to have any
any time anyone who's a minority
particularly a black morty decides to
come out
and do any kind of song or thing for
republicans or trump
they're called being minstrels right
they're getting back
to the minstrel right i wonder if we
have any guests here who have ever been
talked about like that
and yet here we have two gentlemen of
color
dancing for joe biden and yet no one is
going
wait a minute uh guys wait a minute and
yet again the irony are we not seeing
these gentlemen on national tv who are
performing who have made
millions and millions and millions of
dollars able to do and spend
those millions of dollars wherever they
want and yet they're here
supporting a person who's vice president
candidate
called him a rapist yeah and not only
that but he doesn't like he doesn't even
know that they're there
what why couldn't we get cardi b i loved
her in cuties
could you give me a water fellow please
i'm joe biden's husband
i'm common so yes you are you are the
common man the man i want to reach no no
i
am i'm common well you're not we're all
special son
i know i'm common no what
what'd he say you're black you're going
to vote for me right
yo get back in chains what are you
talking about
i do appreciate that you know when they
give the title for julia louis dreyfus
it says
actress first yes because you know she's
not actually living
any of the things that she's talking
about with regards to the policies or
who she supports or
any of that right no she's not even
living up to the uh how dare they show
dr martin luther king a republican yeah
that's a good point i don't think they
know
a lot of people don't know i tell him at
my comedy show he's like what
mother k-1 pumpkin really black people
get pissed when you tell them that yeah
i thought your show was mainly white
people now it is there was a few people
there
yeah especially like when we
transitioned
they would come to our show and they'd
be like what they get pissed off you
tell them that
yeah hey well look these people speak
for you haven't you heard that that
that
white broad with the jerry curls
apparently speaks for the black
community our jobs are evaporating
our faith in the things i wonder why
i wonder why our jobs are evaporating uh
mostly i should know
almost entirely exclusively in blue
states uh we are doing significantly
worse
just just after the covet compared to
our red state brethren
you know these people go home and like
say like man i can't believe i said all
that [ __ ]
it was so hard to just sit there and say
that and keep a straight face yeah
and what's so funny is they try to make
this stick uh donald trump obviously
does
really poorly in a lot of polls but even
after all of this and they've been
trying to lay
the economy at donald trump's feet they
still
trust him the american public still
trust donald trump with the economy more
than joe biden yeah i wish we had a job
boom
like uh
[Laughter]
record setting s p 500 or no yeah
something like that that would be really
good that only that only helps rich
people it doesn't affect main street
oh yeah i thought you supported unions
what do you think is going on with their
pensions
dummies what the dems call it
trickle-down economics
so what the hell kind of bs is that no
they call it trickle-up
yeah because trickle down uh yeah that
made sense
right point out one for your homies well
yeah this porno is calling out cool 45
works everywhere what are the impulses
that have given us slavery can we find a
picture from this decade
you know what i'm not just descending no
human is illegal of course not they're
not from mars
their conduct is illegal they hear
illegally yeah
it's not so much the human itself uh as
it is the uh
the caravan
that went through the border unprotected
in the middle of night where with
sex uh workers under the floor boards
that's really that's if we have to put
our finger on it yeah something that's
more of a problem that we have is really
is
yeah what we do have andrew oh we do
have andrew clavin all right again
the promo code is uh crowd our dmc
stream you get uh 20
off mug club and use the hashtag
crowderdnc stream we'll be reading uh
some of your tweets looking at your
outfits but mr andrew clavin how are you
sir
i'm good how you doing i love that suit
you look like you just came from castle
blanket
really oh come on now isn't that has
that been oh it's gone with the wind was
cancelled
i think miami vice is still allowed
until they find out that don johnson has
been in a couple of more conservative
films like brawl and cellblock 99.
so i'm in the clear um andrew clavin
what is this this is you look like
you're in the in the the the town home
in pacific heights when matthew modine
had kevin uh
had uh michael keaton twist and razor
blades is this this little uh
is this a little garage for you it's the
combination of the noah's ark and the
poseidon adventure for those of your
audience uh
the two people in your audience who know
what the positive is yeah it looks like
it's my it's my loft i am in the loft
well you know what uh next time when you
come on don't make your first reference
a shitty dennis quaid film
oh in the senate hey yeah come on that
was the remake masterpiece
oh i remember i remember i was watching
actually what was it uh the other i'm
not joking now but the other poseidon
the remake whatever it was with the ship
i think it was exciting
i think it was just possible it was just
beside what the boat was called poseidon
yeah that's what we're talking about and
uh i was there with my black manager a
guy named tony camacho he's dominican
and uh we were just sitting and about
halfway through he just said
this [ __ ] all right you want to go leave
i'm like sure
we can do that i don't know if it's just
like a racial divide but like he had no
qualms about the fact that he paid for a
film and didn't want to finish it like
i'm not
into this at all where's my cheap sorry
white ass was like well don't we have to
see what ends maybe it'll redeem the
last two hours of our life lost it we'll
never get back either
got time for this [ __ ] i got stuff to do
i got water to drink um andrew have you
been watching the
convention the previous nights i've been
glued to the set i mean the laughter the
tears the sentimental moments of
reminiscence that
brought our nation together no i haven't
really oh well
the funny thing is you're not off at all
like they just used john lewis as a
springboard to go back to a montage of
firehouses and german shepherds and talk
about how america is more racist than
ever
it's uh it is it just gets worse and
worse it's like a hell pit you know it's
like i don't even understand how anybody
you know how did the black guy next year
how do you get in the building i think
what the hell is going on
kevin i'm not gonna touch that with a
team football
yeah but they didn't qualify for the
african-american they're because they're
52
they qualified for the twin grant
so really it was just we wanted to do a
sketch where we uh we uh
wanted to recreate demolition man and we
couldn't afford a stunt double so
we just knew we'd have two of them
i've been dipping in i've been dipping
in as bill clinton would say into the uh
into the convention from time to time
and uh what i see
in all honesty what i see is a an
endless series
of totally immoral people telling me
that they're better than i am which
i have to tell you is unlikely it really
is unlikely that like bill clinton
uh kamala harris she is so
that woman is so corrupt i mean here's a
woman who literally slept her way into
politics
she's like held back evidence that could
have gotten people out of death row
it's like i thought when you said when
you said she is so and
before you said corrupt i thought you
were going to go indian
[Laughter]
[Music]
she is just so indian
it's just it's just too much it's too
much with the indians it's like a layoff
of the indians exactly it's enough
indian enough
yeah i uh uh yeah it's enough i mean
listen you know you
you do it like you know you do like you
have a bobby jindal
we're good for 12 years
i'm just saying a certain point the
tokenism is all filled up so um
my place here tonight andrew uh what do
you predict we're going to be seeing
from
let's say uh well we already had john
legend and keisha bottoms
joe biden yeah he's he's the one
nobody's talking about
the guy i think he's going to ask the
question that is on everyone's mind
where am i
huh is cutesy still up
it's in my house the best speech of the
convention so far has been
jill biden but i would be a lot i would
have a lot more respect for her if she
would stop them from doing this to her
husband
because it's it's funny if you're cruel
and soulless like myself
right but it's really not you know when
you step back and you actually have some
compassion to try not to go to hell
but a guy who's deteriorating in front
of us
you know it's kind of going to be like
that scene in uh you know the uh
what's the scene with the singer a star
is born
remember the star was born where yeah
yeah yeah no i have no idea what you're
talking about but
the ship is turned upside down and the
story there we go
here we go stop it with the shitty
dennis queen references
it's too niche my comedy's broad
um no i think i i think you're right i
mean this is a demented old this is a
demented old circus monkey at this point
joe biden it really is like someone
should be looking out for him
um i mean if anything really should just
like kamala harris could she could be
the one
she could be the one to save him and
just go out and say like you know what
i said that you were a rapist and i
still think so
see ya you know what let's do a good
night
i just saved you a bunch of money from
having to reverse the ticket later on
down the trail all right i'll be back in
a couple of months to collect my trophy
bye see you later rapist hey by the way
check out his amazon prime and netflix
queue okay it reads like a who's who
of catch a predator all right bye that's
she could end it she could put him out
of his misery
and do you think there was a give her a
couple of months give her a couple of
months she wants to get closer to the
oval office before she does that then
all the bets are off yeah i think you're
uh i think oh is this i'm trying to see
who's on right now
it looked like uh what's her name that
uh late night host it's not her
lily's saying it's not her second andrea
i want you to see this because you know
you're a talented writer i want you to
give us an opinion on uh you know
none of that or them over and over and
over again
but nothing is more dangerous to our
democracy than his attacks hilarious on
mail and voting
during a pandemic okay here's the truth
it's a pin donald trump doesn't want any
of us to vote because he knows he can't
win fair and square
wow or in person
wearing your mask it is your vote
and it's your right don't let donald
trump know take that
away it's not your right to vote by mail
without identification without a process
that's been set up in place
with effectively if it were a company
like the usps that's lost money for
13 years in a row it is your right to
vote
it's not your right to sit at home and
watch your stupid cardi b
and potential presidential candidate
interview and be like i'm gonna vote
though
well how about you do you have any idea
with you nah
well okay well then i guess you
shouldn't race says
you raised stamps though you racist
you know they've got a little problem
with enthusiasm you know it's like they
figured they
might be able to get people to go like
all right dress and then a male hotel
biden but nobody is gonna
i mean really no one in america is gonna
go like yeah i'll get out of this chair
and
walk down the right exactly and vote for
no but i mean who would say that
it's just like you shouldn't make any
sense his next ploy is going to be uh
every vote for joe biden comes with a
free x
chair in your house then it'll just be
like it'll just have to whittle it away
like it'll be a lower back pillow then
maybe a nice like cashmena
but the point is you have to go you're
gonna have to go to people's houses with
like this the
lever you know here's the lever can you
pull it maybe i don't know
even the guy who opened it all right you
even the guy who opened it andrew yang
can we bring up those uh screen have you
seen andrew yang we have the screenshots
of on twitter and instagram where when
joe biden was the nominee
people were saying i can't believe this
is happening and he this is andrew
yang's like i understand and know the
feeling
you endorsed him and you were the number
one person to speak
like he even even even his party even
people who were on the docket don't like
him
like eventually steph curry is going to
just come out and be like listen i know
he's i know he's just i know he's a
piece of [ __ ] but
he's our piece of [ __ ] and he's like
under like you know a couple of dribbles
through the legs and it was like ah
cheer for steph curry and then brian
stealth edited it together like it was
for joe biden
and is anyone pissed that or these
people should be pissed that joe biden
has spoken
with none of them none of them he spoke
with the forgive me
the wet [ __ ] girl that's who he gave
the interview to
it's like i want to make sure that the
person i give a scoop is really worthy
of oh blow jobs and barbecue ribs
because she's dry as hell too well
that's what she says
she says that's why she's you know
giving a medical advice to children like
uh uh kevin jennings what were you about
to say there uh andrew clavin she's
driving well i do like the fact that the
press has been complaining for four
years that donald trump
is a threat to the first amendment
because he points out that they lie all
the time
this guy literally he literally hasn't
answered a question
from any reporter in two months and when
they ask him questions it's always like
where'd you get that tie
you know i like that tie it's a very
nice you know yeah am i wearing a tie
where am i
you know no it's uh it's a bib
oh a tie how'd that get there and i
i heard that like hunter biden is hunter
biden literally going to be at this
place
is that true i i heard that no no
they'll be playing a game hunting biden
where it's just they give everyone an
old winchester they give them
double-barreled shotguns and a
recreation porch and they just fire into
the air to see if he shits himself i
thought he was going to fly in on his
private jet that he bought with the
profits from his
ukrainian deal with 50 000 a day
you watch your mouth that man is an
energy expert sir
yeah it'd be like me hiring you to fix
my plumbing for half a mil
hey i really like true crime how do you
do with copper wiring
okay give me a that's a wrench isn't it
yeah i would like a wrench tonight so i
can beat myself over the head with it
just because i don't i think that if i
shot myself um
it would it would be like it would i
need to suffer at least
close to as much as i will having to
watch the rest of this so if i just hit
my head
myself in the head with a wrench it
would be the equivalent this is the
other thing this
is this is truly boring i mean i you
know i i do
have some sympathy for the fact that
they had to do it all uh you know
in this uh online virtual way but they
are really dull and
you know the only thing that's
interesting about them is recounting how
corrupt they are
you know it's the only thing that's
interesting about watching bill clinton
is thinking like wait isn't that the guy
who like
stuck a cigar and a girl young enough to
be his daughter
about what we should do for our nation
and cardi b he's like that would be
inadvised if you want to keep this [ __ ]
wet
don't be put don't be putting no don
don't be putting no john fuentes up in
your hooch
that's what ash pushes you i think it's
a little bit
it's the follow up oh
i hate that this is america
like just the thing of it the equivalent
would be like i'm trying to think the
equivalent would be like if i guess
maybe
uh uh like if uh mondale
were being you know if the equipment
would be if like bill clinton were
interviewed let's even go there
like salt and pepper right and like
people like oh he's gonna do with the
push-it broads
this is gonna be in the oval office
it's like it's just so disgusting that
these are the role models for young
girls right now
like if it were jfk i'm trying to think
of maybe crosstalk like maybe be like
diana ross or aretha franklin like
asking about relevance
this guy the only interview he's given
that's right the only interview joe
biden's given that i know
only interviews cardi b cardi b he did
it because
because somebody told them i'm sure this
is why i did it somebody told them
that young black people are looking at
this guy and saying
are you kidding me
the older black people are going wait if
it wasn't him it was going to be bernie
sanders and the young people
yeah and killer killer mike is out there
endorsing bernie sanders and the only
reason that black people couldn't get on
board
like yeah yummy the cracker who uh
autumn [ __ ] stole his mic
and he didn't do nothing he's supposed
to be my brother the guy who didn't do
nothing
came up there like i'll burn it that's
all mike now he was like yeah
white boy punk the future president what
a [ __ ]
do you lean over and slap this guy you
shouldn't be doing this material
i should absolutely be doing this
material that's wrong
let's see uh black lives matter what
does fauci
say uh big fan of the final question
on a scale from one to ten how do you
rate the united states post office
andrew clavin
what what why do you know listen i have
to say this first
my post lady is one of my favorite
people she is like the nicest person
she comes is she white no you right
she's white everyone sees a supremacy
but go ahead
she's just the nicest human being the
place should be shut down why on earth
do we have a post
what's tell me one thing that we do with
the post office nothing
it's catalogs it's catalogs catalogs
guys you can get bills you can pay bills
online
it's over the post office is over the
idea
i don't know hey hey listen every time i
do your show
they say to me don't forget to plug the
andrew clavin show on the daily wire and
i always forget because i'm too busy
fighting with you but well maybe you
should go plug it to your post lady
[Laughter]
by the time you get that plug it'll be
what you know next year exactly
you'll be coming in with a bunch of like
well i don't want to piss off a good
contingency of our audience
it consists of couponers so i don't want
them to be we don't want to lose a
coupon or audience
yeah they just drop they're not watching
how else are they going to get their
gain at 32 cents off
[Laughter]
all right so it is the andrew clavin
show of course on the daily wire you're
there
ben shapiro is there michael knowles is
there uh
he cares about them i just just played
the game
i just wanted to make sure that i paint
the full picture in that it's a who's
who of
uh exclusively white
exactly exactly that's a rule i mean you
know it's an old rule but you know
we're fond of it yeah because you know
you're in los angeles where could you
find someone of color
all right thank you mr clavin we
appreciate it
all right see ya bye uh all right who do
we got going on here this guy
oh joe biden's talking no no he went and
found random strangers who could speak
better than him
[Laughter]
we have an ongoing goal i need more
volume guys i can't even find a house in
the next five years so
um hopefully we'll save save save look
everybody you talked about the middle
class
the fact is that why was he answering
her and then moving to someone talking
yeah
look he talked about the middle class
who's she
what'd he say you're asking because one
generation
next the equity in a home you know the
middle class
is continuous taking hits and one of the
reasons why we're on this call is we
realize how important
it is to no we can bring up reg the
bandit actually here regen appreciate
the numbers the middle class is doing
better than ever in the history of the
united states they had the average
income increase
in the first few years of donald trump i
believe it was about 5 000 something
dollars as opposed to one thousand
dollars under
eight years of barack obama reg the
bandit i think you have that number
there it's
i don't have it in front of me i pretty
much just have a schedule it's something
along those lines correct it wasn't like
a five thousand dollar
average salary increase in the first two
years under donald trump compared to
eight under barack obama and they're
also paying an average of sixteen
hundred dollars less in taxes
yeah i think that's about right all
right
as a matter of fact it gets to the point
that's what i love about that i'll
i'll get you the overlay in a second but
yeah it's it's a it's an exponential
increase
compared to what you see under obama and
people like that um
so yeah and then we also have you know
wait hold on a second do you guys see
this we have
it's indian ezra klein oh yeah look
delicious
come on yeah someone bring up ezra klein
and
otherwise i'm gonna be pissed because
you're gonna leave me out and hang and
get a bigger picture
indian ezra
it's hard to tell with kamala harris
meeting the criteria yeah she kind of
muddies the waters a little bit
you're guessing as good as my colleagues
recline
no he's definitely african-american
really dead what
come on oh his nut his name is dr vivek
murthy
[Laughter]
would you like to revise your answer sir
his cousin's eddie murphy
i think his nickname is leroy
yeah do you think there's tension in
that household there's a little bit of
jealousy
he quite didn't live up to the standards
of eddie
what if he just showed up in a leather
blue jumpsuit
[Laughter]
uh what are we about to say there reg
[Laughter]
can we not forget that you know joe
biden in answering those questions
literally earlier you're just hearing a
bunch of random people with no facts
spouting things that they think might be
the
might be facts and then you've got joe
biden going uh-huh
and now you're answering i'm not even
answering them direct correct right like
someone asks a nonsensical question
that really could be answered vaguely
and he's so uncomfortable on his feet
that he's like uh-huh
i think earlier this man was saying that
we're in a new revolution that guy's
like what the [ __ ]
i didn't say anything about that yeah
that's what i heard some of someone here
say
maybe it was the fat yeah we do have a
chat
uh that says uh my my income has
increased by 25
since trump took office i have hoped for
a real life for the first time gary oh
well that's anecdotal but i'm glad to
hear it g
squared yeah and then uh garrett says
he's making more money than he ever has
hey you're not supposed to talk about
your raises it makes the other employees
for me especially especially too cute
maddie she's getting 77 cents on your
quarter black dollar
but i'm quarterback money doesn't grow
on trees for women
but you know what you know what because
of systemic
feminazis no because of systemic
racism and misogyny there's no way that
there could be a wisconsin senator
that's a woman oh wait look at cnn
yeah like the liberty bell
do we want to listen to timmy baldwin no
listen i gotta take a leak so
let's uh let's go to uh a break you know
what uh can we put in the
slightly yeah let's put in the short
break uh we'll go to a short break we'll
come back with more of your chat and uh
hopefully not enough oh
next is tammy duckworth all right we'll
play a game or something we'll figure it
out you don't need to be watching
tammy's
openly gay person
[Music]
oh hi uh seen on the board do you guys
have
black rifle coffee here no i'm sorry we
only carry
good small batch coffee here well it is
great small batch coffee well that
really can't be unless it's
fresh roasted so i don't you know what
is fresh fresh sticks
i don't i don't think you know what that
means you know what this
is this is masa le cua pique
which of course in the indonesian let me
finish in the indonesian language
it's weasel coffee you just made that up
no it's been passed through their
digestive tract that's disgusting and
then
it's nature's wet processing yeah but is
it good
[Music]
i mean it's all right are they investor
philanthropists do they support good
causes yeah tons of causes
veterans causes and first responder
causes but it doesn't matter because
they make good coffee so that's what i'm
wanting
do you have any you know what actually
i'm i'm just going to order it
they make it fresh and roasted black
rifle coffee
it's good
so i've decided to hijack the show
because everyone else has
a tiny tiny woman-like baby-like bladder
except for everyone here humanity water
black audio wave huge bladder so we've
got coming up steph curry
you know what's funny about this is
they've been showing steph curry's face
since the very beginning
yeah because they want to keep people
interested and every time they have a
break they're like it's next
oh sorry stephen uh sorry
we didn't get to okay so here's all
right hey joe lewis
place hold it hold it good boy sit well
hold on a second there you go
you'll be my co-host for a little bit
joe lewis thank you so
the podge twins for the first time in
their adult life decided to go to the
bathroom
joe let's you're in the microphone path
here let's move back
they decided to joe lewis just move they
decided to go
they decided they usually pee together
holding hands
and then and then uh uh token said well
stephen why don't you just go outside
and i went outside and it's the
gymnastics class from next door they're
doing stretches
so i would have been like a registered
sex offender in the next episode of
cutesies
no so my bladder is about to explode uh
all right let's see what does let's see
what joe biden has to say
what he has to say eight months ago
are there are they alive are they
allowed to broadcast this as live are
they allowed to label it yeah
yeah that's kind of rough there's got to
be so many different inputs
you're a better you're a better co-host
than those two twins of color who just
take
they're both taking don't you say that
it's a white you even have more
you have more bowel just another white
dog taking over
by the way we don't know this is the
bully lean that we talk about where he
just leans on you
and gives you your seat's been taken
[ __ ]
wow all right bill can you handle it for
just a couple minutes yeah i'll go to
the bathroom
or you can stay there all right joel
come on come on
all right there we go we got the seats
back we do have a tweet
get out of here bill we have a tweet for
you uh let's hear it
it says i love that bill richmond
dressed as short round from temple of
doom
was that your intention is spot on well
i'm not gonna lie
when i was a shorter boy i was short
around no yes that is exactly it okay
yeah yeah look i got i gotta i gotta go
with these right if i'm not recognize a
short round in public
it's because i'm kim jong-un and so you
just gotta you gotta go with what god
gave you together
so hold on can we can we see what's on
cnn right now look at this they are
celebrating
veterans of america but never has a
party been so consistently
against the the military and what they
stand for i mean we've got
um amazing people in this country who
have been a part of serving
and spreading democracy and yet here
they are saying oh
oh we want to celebrate our veterans we
want to celebrate our military
and they're doing anything but what
they're doing this whole time is trying
out people
and saying oh this is the people we
support this is his faith his faith well
it's like
yeah anything he actually stands for
they want to play videos of people
protesting the war and people at the
same time in the war
at the same time and say these are we
represented by both of these people
right so you know
you see what they just said uh this
election is bigger than politics
i'm sorry i'm sorry what have we been
watching every night unfortunately
we've been watching the same thing yeah
i think it literally actually is
politics gosh i hurt my back
by the way looking terrible no no i hurt
my back
moving this guy around we have a video
coming out we did jiu jitsu and i just
heard like a little
i snapped my [ __ ] up man i snapped my
[ __ ] up
what were you guys talking about what i
missed well we were talking about
the uh political use of veterans to try
and convince uh america that the dnc is
actually
oh they never veterans did some guy like
roll himself out in a skateboard without
legs and [ __ ]
uh no they they just plopped him there
and then made fun of him oh
yeah they said how could you support
these republican wars you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] this isn't an
in-person event
we're live yeah you won't put on an 80s
jacket but
he'll bring this potty mouth yes yes i
will
bring but he'll bring his his street
lingo
no no i'm standing on the shoulder pad
so i can be a little taller you are
standing on the shoulder pads of lesser
half asians i'm glad you grabbed that's
good
tiger woods
the bandit do we have those sources on
the middle class stuff i i know that
i was yeah what was it uh yeah we do
have an overlay
um there we go okay yeah yeah so so
trump outperformed both bush and obama
so you had within eight years under
george bush
then about a thousand under obama and
then under trump in a very short period
of time
you had 5 000 increase in income
so i was right i said a thousand and
eight years under obama 5 000 under
trump
you know i should trust myself more
youtube
you did this to me you should you did
this to me youtube you made me doubt
myself
by browbeating me for a year and a half
you just need a motivational poster
half asian bill getting uncomfortable
because he's like don't try converting
the conversation
i'm just thinking about all the work i
get to do oh believe me i'll make sure
you have it cut out for you
uh who is this right this is another
tammy see
oh jill i couldn't tell what's the clown
makeup
oh oh hey hey you didn't see it but my
eye naturally goes to the fine print so
right before they zoomed in at the
bottom it said
use of dod footage does not should not
constitute or does not constitute
an endorsement of military activity so
guys
don't worry they're literally crossing
their fingers behind their back but in
the front
because they wouldn't want our military
to engage in activity that is
of them we would hate for them to be
endorsed
to think we're behind them they bring
out steph curry like just so you know
hashtag not all basketball players okay
hashtag we just we don't endorse the nba
right just so
you under and you guys aren't big fans
of lebron you just uh did a video used
to be man big fan of lebron man but
what you till he came out politically i
said man this guy's a [ __ ]
what made you what made you what made
you uh think he's a [ __ ] is this what's
the
stupid hat that didn't even work uh as
far as all the
the hypocrisy comes out of his mouth
about our president he talks down to him
it's like
they win a series they don't want to go
to the white house i'm like man just
stop being a kid
grow up be a man well joe biden can
teach him a lesson or two in that
no he's still in remedial manhood hey
hey hey we're calling we're calling
behind the benjamin button
mentally he's just
[Music]
we have to draw here because donald
trump went into office looking so weird
like you can't really you can't tell the
age like you know he's not like
he's always been dying his hair blonde
already for a decade
so um oh thank you i don't is this uh is
he george it's like uh
yeah oh wow well my aunt has a picture
with his face on it
but that was a um a picture i'm not
gonna say something yeah picture with
the face of rod stewart oh ladies love
him
horrible hey you know she has a face her
face is up here people
wow gratuitous lost leg shot
[Laughter]
[Music]
look she you gotta keep that [ __ ]
lubricated
like the tin man
[Laughter]
you stupid purple
commander trooper i can walk away the
hours with my personal flowers
i want y'all to remember when y'all
thinking jovan think this
cooch when y'all voting joe biden think
about this snook it's like come on
i'm taking everything off the screen so
they could gift that yeah absolutely all
done
tammy duckworth is a fan of it she knows
what i'm talking about with her stupid
shark necklace
oh thank you very much rod stewart i
appreciate it you know
when you when you think about tammy
duckworth this is the thing you've got
to think look at look at her look at her
bio down there
in the lower coke's been corked you've
got just disintegrated
a veteran purple heart recipient former
assistant secretary of veteran affairs
and yet in her fourth year in the senate
illinois still one of the most corrupt
terrible awful states in the entire
union you can't even be an amazing
veteran
who was injured in war who has done
amazing things
in war and logistics you can't get
illinois right
and not only that like the funny thing
is nobody
cares here at this like that's why they
start with the everything that you just
listed
they're like uh-huh yeah yeah can we
show the mechanical leg yeah just tilt
the camera back down please we have like
uh doing like a glycerin bottle we can
spray on there i really like it
hey did we check this box for you great
we earned your vote right i'm gonna tell
you
i heard one of the founders bt the
founder of bt
talking about how when he was asked the
party to go to the democratic national
convention and said hey
we want you guys to advertise on bt they
go why we have you guys all right
legit legit they did that that's how
taking for granted
the minority vote is because they're
trotting people out but they're not even
talking about
the ideals the values you know i know
we're going to get in the comments
let them talk what are they actually
talking about guys we already know what
they're talking about and it's nothing
there's nothing yeah there's a surface
level
guys we got it you got to change the
system because this white guy he's
better than the the
other white guy but we hate but also
white guys are bad
and cardi b's doing a license right now
like i like to terminate a [ __ ]
is she not the terminator who could like
change shape she's like the one who's
like i'll be back
isn't there gotta be there's gotta be an
artist out there if he was going for
like a black female who just isn't awful
nope well there's like isn't like is it
nicki minaj a class act
nicki minaj she makes nicki minaj like
she's gonna run for president
yeah i mean she's totally classic
compared to uh
cardi b just who else do we have right
now actually
i mean you can just get beyonce i mean
yeah she's from texas
they're singers from destiny's childhood
no they're all they're yeah no beyonce
buried them
oh yeah they're not going is that
because they were more attractive than
her
i don't know i stopped following them
when they rhymed uh down like that was
down like that
19 times take charlie's angel song can
we do a quick count i'm just curious
maybe regular band
can do this because i'm curious how many
images they're going to show of beau the
good son
versus hunter the promiscuous child
having widow dating
son yeah no
nobody cares about this one all right
let's let's see let's see what that what
is this what is that
it's just this is nothing but pre-rolls
tonight yeah yeah it's not even live
clips
yeah it still says live on there it's
like dave chappelle or kean peel tossing
to sketches
families who are freer because of him
some folks may never know that their
lives are better because of beau biden
but that's okay there it is right there
at the bottom again use of dod footage
does not constitute a support public
service if you knew beau
you knew he lived by the strictest oh
they're going bow now like he's
jackson service here he can play two
sports at once
you never had to ask if he would do
something the right way
he didn't know any other way he just
ended
he chose to finish his job as a.g
instead
after 9 11 he joined the national guard
he felt it was his obligation
he did his duty to his country and
deployed to iraq
beau biden served his country in battle
he prosecuted one what was his full name
was it ball bob
his full name yeah but wasn't short for
something
[Music]
that's the southern name no i'm an
[ __ ]
i thought for sure i have no idea
i don't care so i have something to ask
of you hey when are we getting a montage
for hunter
yeah i want to see the black seafood
but he's one rich black sheep he's got
that on us
oh it's bo spelled like french like bo
means like handsome
okay very nice i had no idea i was
thinking but bo jackson the southern
thing
b o is bo jackson what was that short
for people who called me
nothing b.o is different from bo i know
they are different it's just bo
they're just b.o well that's silly i
have no idea
current president has made me cry too
but it's never had anything to do with
his oh bill clinton got to you oh my god
that's the vortex velocity of his nasal
cavity
suction god i'm never gonna watch
seinfeld again
god man she looks good though she always
looked great but
yes sir fat [ __ ] crazy liberals no no
they got an actress guys
they're just paying her she's like this
is a gig
ovid you gotta take what you can get
just make sure you put first
actress and then convention moderator oh
hey look
it's pete buttgig let's see what he has
to say good evening what what me worry
is that a wedding reception in office
i see i see he remembered his hair in a
can tonight
he looked like bring up that picture of
him when he was doing like a skype call
on cnn or something and he was clearly
bald
because it's a country you believe in
like you ever see those late night
commercials where like your wife will
never know
man that's what he uses look at the
space between his nose and his lip he
could grow one hell of a mustache
he has a space to grow mustache yeah
there's a lot of i mean if he grows
mustache up man that'd be some thick
stash
he did it's there it's there it's right
there there's no testosterone to push it
out though
hormonally he didn't he can't grow his
dad i mean he has the real estate
yeah he could probably grow one main
gate mustang
oh yeah we do do we have the overlay of
him we're getting it pulled up
all right we're gonna pull up the
overlay and by the way i know like this
isn't a debate night
this is a non-event in case people are
tuning in why aren't you showing more of
it
they've said zero yeah this is it yeah
there's no way to fact-check nothing
look at that that's what you
it looks like it looks like uh like pete
buttgig was seated in a poddling chair
and dark crystal and new pete butt gig
sucked out half his shoulder
did he get a hair transplant we also
have biden's hair plug
oh look at that yeah it looks like an
artificial christmas tree
hey don't knock those artificial
christmas trees i like artificial
christmas
all right let's hear what he has to say
in front of his uh little uh
solar powered night lights imagine what
we could achieve
this coalition we are building this very
season
gathering progressives and moderates
independents
and even what i like to call future
former republicans
you crazy
he lost he lost their own viewers at
moderates
why the hell would a republican join the
democrats the modern democracy
could be out of work want a free handout
no they're too classy to do that
i don't know struggle to call out what
is good
what do we have here oh yeah the ratings
dropped
i think we have the overlays here the
ratings are down 48
from 2016. wonder why
and then um what's funny though is that
if we bring up the cnn tried to claim it
was only 26 percent
and the reason is because they say well
if you add all the cable
uh then then it's actually 26 percent if
you're comparing it to
only the networks from before no no
compare the networks to networks right
which is what matters because those are
the tables
same stats it's a 48 drop from 2016. you
must have those overlays
yeah we're getting pulled up
did you guys i didn't realize this and
in red you could fact check it but my
understanding is that the first
night of the convention drew 25 less
viewers
than in 2016. no no it's 48 48 percent
lower
he wasn't listening to me at all 30
seconds ago
no it's 48 that one's wrong that's the
second night
convention first they're down 48 total
from 20 yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah the first night when they
didn't know you know
so the number you're sighting that's cnn
that's the number if you add
all the cable networks the cable news
network and the problem is that's not
usually the metric because those
networks are always running whatever is
political all i hear is you're admitting
i'm right
no i literally i have it written right
here i said cnn tries to claim it's only
26
and then my lawyer who's supposed to be
on my side says cnn is right
he's a stealther fan no i don't need
jeffy
[Laughter]
hold on let's see uh turtles club booker
how shocked they would all be if he said
to a woman like because he
because he's smarter than you they'd be
like oh
what the [ __ ] how could you ever see
your gay man is smarter than a woman in
a mushroom cut
and i actually do think clubbing sharks
is probably smarter than all of them i'm
not gonna lie so we do have the cnn
overlay it looks like the first night of
the 2020
was down 25 percent but again they're
using the number adding up
all cables that's what matters is you
need to compare abc nbc cbs to abcmccbs
they're trying to compare specifically
abcmccbs msnbc cnbc
and that's the point is like every other
objective well i don't want to say
objective but
uh most news outlets and using a
consistent comparison it was down 48
and they're trying to do the cable
comparison hold on i want to hear what
klobuchar has to say because she's a cut
up
his kindness for calling me and being a
mentor but it also goes to how much he
cares about our government
and what a lot of people talking about
and that even when he's at home
at night i've seen his passions watching
really excited for his speech yeah yeah
and amy we all want to know
did your mother watch the speech yes
that's what everyone wants to know about
the potential leader
of the free world everyone wants to know
does your mother
make good potatoes why don't you
no i think that's pretty much uh that's
probably likely in all of politics
and i mean that all of them hate cory
booker
did you see his fake laugh face yeah
he's like
we're friends like he's losing his angel
virginity
that happened
and then by the way that's the guy's
going to be the guns are vader o'rourke
who uh
yeah good luck with that after you've
just had the john brown
socialist gun club you have more
liberals buying guns than ever before
because they're afraid of their own
looters and rioters and for some reason
white supremacists
and then you have more first-time gun
buyers than ever and what happened did
she did she get her hair cut by that
vacuum suction hair cutter in wayne's
world what happened with that right now
does she give me
say give me the legend of zelda link to
the past
uh sideburn action going on here it's
like everyone here has deliberately had
a crappy haircut
yeah just because they want everyone to
know that they can't go to a barber
because they take covet seriously
i think blinkers got the best haircut
yeah i do appreciate that
most of them aren't even pretending to
act like they're interested in being
here
like if you look at their faces they're
like all right is this over especially
klobuchar
she's like really guys kamala
yeah really guys and you know what's
worse than being on a zoom call
watching someone else's zoom club
why are we watching 20 zoom calls in one
night this is horrible
stay tuned after this bill clinton will
jerk off on skype is
just like in a local library he's like
guys i need i need this
is this i need this no was it he was
role playing for his only fans account
he was like oh let me stop by and
endorse this ah you know if i endorse
this guy on the zoom call he's going to
make me gunzar
i don't know buttons up his sharian
buttons up his short rides off on a
skateboard radical
faith in this country yang's got his
graph calculator look i spelled boobs
uh george joe biden because he's what
you got but he's so handsome
and their urgency in the campaign that
they're running and the administration
that they're going to lead
and i often think some people say they
don't know if they're going to oh this
is a pre-taped zoom caller
each one of them it's got a little vomit
can and
they're gonna have to kill yeah they
even try and hide it it's like three in
the afternoon
no i'm uh i'm uh in uh i'm in uh brazil
it's the same time zone you're just
going down south
oh who is dangerous i'm in donna i'm in
dawn of brazil
i'm in the ussr well okay we buy it all
right bernie you're off the hook
at this country score one for the burn
man and all of us
whether you're progressives whether
you're moderates
or whether you're moderates by the way
speaking of moderates
and you would think go ahead ain't
nobody in the democratic party is a
modern anymore
do you know that they that biden's lead
over trump dropped by two points after
he announced kamala harris
i don't even think he was mean to begin
with
but the fact that even the fake polls
haven't dropped hey look it's the guy
who banned slurpies
yes the guy who wanted to pat down a
bunch of black people
all about people and the two people
running for president
couldn't be more different one believes
in
mouth one does not one listens to
experts
the other thinks he knows everything are
they talking about kamala versus
joe or america's diversity the other
looks
backwards and sees immigrants you just
ran a montage
of fire hoses and german shepherds in
mlk
and you said that donald trump looks
backwards no donald i guess you could
in a manner speaking he looks backwards
to january or february when black
unemployment was at an all-time low in
this country
technically that's a little bit of a
glance in your rear-view mirror careful
shitty mayors may be larger than they
appear
it is unreal to me that they're talking
about one's looking back
all joe biden has done is run on the
platform of racial division and hatred
and by the way
he was the guy sewing those seats back
then
so so look at this look at this thing at
the bottom here
worth 55 billion per forbes these are
the things you're going to put on here
right tammy duckworth you got talking
about her her veteran history
her purple heart you got this guy hey i
just want to make sure
at the end of this i want to remind
everyone that this guy was running for
the democratic
presidential ticket and he's still
hoarding 55 billion dollars but don't
worry he's going to give everyone else's
billions away
especially you middle class we're going
to give it all away just trust him
the same part that wants to get money
out of politics yeah all right
let me see what he has to say this way
before i ran for mayor i spent 20 years
running a business i started from
scratch
so i want to ask small business owners
and their employees
shut down indefinitely and it's a
question for everyone
would you rehire or work for someone who
ran your business into the ground
and who always does what's best for him
or her
he is quite literally describing the
only thing we know about joe biden's
policy
is that you should have a never-ending
shutdown would you vote again for the
guy who shut your business down and ran
it into the crowd
you just they are making the case for
president donald trump
they are so tone-deaf they they just you
could not
reach out to an audience that would hate
you more
than small business owners right now
yeah
from new york city 14 000 14
000 empty apartments in new york city
there aren't 14 000 billionaires on the
list
let alone manhattan they've left because
you've screwed them
the only thing they left were some
plywood boards up on their business and
some wire that was too small for a mouth
i cannot believe it this guy just call
out the small business owner saying
would you rehire donald trump
call out to anyone like call out to the
honduran caravan call out to
cardi b's instagram followers don't try
and call
call small business owners to the floor
bloomberg wait so i guess what he's
saying is if you want to hire a business
owner hire the guy who's a career
politician
who's made less money as a private job
than i'm sure
baron trump's lemonade stand when he was
nine who would force all businesses to
shut down indefinitely except for the
businesses that he would force at
gunpoint to double the testing somehow
are they actively trying to lose like
that's what all i'm seeing is that
they're actively trying to lose yeah
you know what i wonder that i'm not a
conspiratorial guy but is is is
that's what it is joe biden pulling a
jake lamata
but in the last three three and a half
years he hasn't done
anything what a joke
[Laughter]
what a joke what a what a what a palooka
was that good what does that mean i can
do it again what a joke what a
joke guys give me some aside this time
what a joke
right fellow small business owners and
negroes
trying to tell the difference between me
and a company what a
i don't know can i i mean they don't
give you a pass at all man
i would stay away from the word negro
far away well i didn't say it i was
quoting him yeah yeah see it's character
work
careful i told you that my mom says
negroes right she said it for a long
time when she moved here because she's
french
and she was trying to say the less
offensive and so it's even worse when
she's foreign because like you know they
assume she's some like eastern promises
russian mafia
right right look there's a bunch of
negroes over there
no she didn't say that all of that no
they're negroes
no she did say that she's like uh denzel
washington you know for me like he's
people like that's the thing it doesn't
matter white or negro he's a very good
looking guy you're like oh my god mom
stop that
please stop being what you are
[Laughter]
will bring integrity and stability
sanity and competence
back to enough confidence
these like this i feel like we're
watching a hostage video with every
single one of these
they've got their hands tied look at him
scammer what was this [ __ ]
was it judd judge not judge reinhold
judd nelson
breakfast club he's like yeah he's
expecting like he's expecting wham to
start playing
yeah don't you
that's joe no literally joe don't forget
about me please
i'd like a cabinet position anyone can
do it
i want an interesting i don't know i
don't know if yeah i don't think
bloomberg
can earlier this year but that was
really funny by the way do you like the
subtle messaging where they show
all blue states it's a fantasy it'll
never happen yeah
my name is brayden harrington and i'm 13
years old
she doesn't seem to be brainwashed oh do
you see he just looked off camera to the
guy with a gun
daddy please don't beat me don't you
mess up boy yeah
chosen they're there i'll sniff you kid
it's just his black adoptive mother
snapping a belt
[Laughter]
what's the stutter oh he's really
amazing he's got a stutter
he's got his stuff
it is so mean to parade a kid out
because it's like they said oh we need
some
we we don't have enough pre-recorded
zoom calls bernie really screwed the
pooch by uh
by broadcasting it from his summer beach
home number four so we could see the
afternoon can we go grab some more
endorsements from the make-a-wish
foundation
man what the hell is going on i'm braden
and i'm being used
yeah no no no guys there's a very
strategic watches blinks being used i
think
i can register the bandit they can
please inform me because i want to hurt
myself
so there's a pretty specific reason
they're having a kid with a stutter on
they're saying the talking point for
biden with his gaffes
and his chronic uh you know miss
speaking
from the democratic party is that he has
a stutter
that's that's what it just develops i
just sent you a
newsweek piece that you know is is
giving apologies saying oh you know uh
it's because
biden has a stutter cnn ran a puff piece
saying
biden opens up about stuttering and
offers advice to young people who
stutter
and so that's that's a talking point
that you never heard you know
in past elections everyone just laughed
and said oh yeah joe biden he's always
making gaffes whatever but as it's
gotten worse and worse
now it's like no no no he has a
disability so you can rooster
you can't make fun of that started this
year i've never developed
i've never heard of a stutter causing
you to make up places that don't exist
and lie about meetings with people
you've never seen in person
there are amazing and incredible people
who have stutters who make it through
but they don't have these kinds of
gaffes
you can't go through like john right and
he had his eustachian tube
crushed like the kid from like the
kitten it's a wonderful life from that
damn pharmacist by that wrestler guy
and he still made a go of it i mean look
but that kid's not forgetting where he
is
i mean he knows exactly right on a
studio
inside of another prison being told to
say these things i mean
oh my gosh that just like i feel so is
it not so transparent
all they're talking about is our
strength is our diversity here's a lady
with a bionic leg
hey look here's someone with progeria
kid
turn up your stutter exploding the kid
with a stutter yeah and are we supposed
to think donald trump donald trump is
like beating disabled kids like what
was like oh no joe biden's pro-disabled
kid yeah
and by the way keep in mind that this is
the party who said that uh sarah right
they should have aborted the uh
the the baby with a disability and also
mocked right santorum
yeah same party the same party who
actually support eugenics right they
believe that
abortion that abortion should be an
option if uh not only do they believe it
should be an option if your baby
has a defects but they believe in sex
selective abortion like china
sorry half asian bill this is his
granddaughters
these are the granddaughters the briars
that have half chocolate happiness oh my
god
like i'm supposed to care we're talking
about what ice cream he likes that he
drools down his bib
ah i told you not to get the hoggins dad
give my money to those mexicans
i only want briars is this the kroger
brand
oh i [ __ ] myself again oh dad
stephen what's wrong with your
impression is that he's feeding himself
yeah
that's right it's just jill going he's
like
guys don't worry a vote for biden is a
vote for
more white people so that's the dnc
model legacy
keep it up guys we're in favor of
minorities except for president i wonder
how joe biden would treat them at the
thanksgiving table if they started uh
just reciting cardi b
all right who are you are you cardi b
hey grandpa pass the potatoes my white
person
that's not what we do
you're disgusting you're a disgusting
grandmother
that's why i'm so ashamed that's not
what we do here family we only do that
for votes
[Laughter]
by the way how much do you want to bet
that that kid knew he was going to be on
national television so he worked
really hard to clean up his stutter
showed up went through the run through
they're like no no no no
when we first watched the stuff go back
to that they definitely used the worst
take because they're using it absolutely
you know when he was like yeah doing all
this crazy they kept having him retake
it until he got tired
like here here's have a little whiskey
loosen the nerves good
whiskey's good how's that stutter doing
gosh
so manipulative is it still is it still
is your stutter
is it still okay enough to make an
endorsement but bad enough that we can't
tell
action he should at least use an adult
man why
guys i appreciate though that all the
photos i've seen of joe biden tonight
the ones that they've selected he has no
uh mustard or ketchup stains which is a
big big thing it's an improvement okay
i mean that's because that's because
they actually just cover them in
cellophane like
greek families with their furniture oh
hey
what happened to my briars hey what the
african americans talking about
let's see hey look it's stiff hey they
look they all look like me
it's a good looking family though how
are those 10 year olds voting
[ __ ] [ __ ]
he's got both
do you know where the kids are trying to
escape guys is it just me or just do
that husband wife look like brother and
sister
what the president's job is
i'm asking for a friend please tell me
yeah joe asked me to ask this
he's jealous if
you could create the ideal
person to lead this country what
characteristics i know what they're
going to say
ask a kid very kind personality
what would you like to see taken care of
i would like to see
how do you feel about the man sniffing
your scalp
let's ask a child what are we doing it
is 20
20 and the election is coming up they
wouldn't let joe by in the long run with
those kids
i guarantee you they would not let joe
biden alone with those kids they know
exactly how that would go like hey
oh look at the you come back from a
cruise
no nobody's just having my hair oh i
have my my daughter
who did one time on the cruise
[Music]
all right once we pour the beer i think
we're going to do a truth according to
smooth manny segment because apparently
all right i got to warn y'all when i get
alcohol it's going to turn into a hot
mic
just careful you're ready to turn it off
you guys can say some words that the
court of black can kind of get away with
yeah we need to pour it in their mugs
there
because we don't want to be sued by the
bomb
it's got juice in it yeah i need some
new mugs
yeah you didn't even check their mug for
juice oh no
she's a real she's really pretty though
steph curry's we've been steph curry's a
really good looking guy and you know
what they seem pretty sharp it's just
it's just a shame to see them
effectively being poured out on this to
the highest bidder right now
because you know what guess what the
reason this is uh
this is something that i actually think
would connect with most americans is
because it goes against everything the
democratic party stands for
family husband and wife raising children
traditional gender roles
here's the big question yeah how much of
your time and energy
are you willing to devote to elect joe
biden
none because it's going to take a lot of
money
it's this evening well you put a gun to
me and i still ain't voting for it
how's the mail in voting right now yeah
right now this is where they do it
this year we're going to elect a
president who's honest
experienced and intelligent a president
who's not one out of three ain't bad
experience that's for sure wow did she
just call trump stupid
and oh no what are we gonna do
one of my favorite things joe biden says
to read prompter
she's also blinking sos or your
commitment to family
so who better to introduce our nominee
joe biden than his children
uh someone qualified hunter hunter
bring him out ashley a tv host joe biden
is our dad
how long he's going to be talking for i
thought it was going to go on for way
longer what kind of president
oh we've already been on for two hours
and honest
caring honestly he looked like he was
wincing when he said
honestly even when you don't want to
hear me
his left eye is not even moving that's
because he threw up in his mouth a
little bit ever
lean on he'll beam with pride every time
you succeed
who'll make your grandkids feel that
what they've got to say
matters he'll treat him with respect
no matter who you are he'll get up no
matter how many times he's been knocked
down
he'll be there because he uses life
alert
he'll be the best friend you've ever had
he'll love you with all of his talk
he'll be the first man in the white
house to put it in a reverse mortgage
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
uh i assume so somebody take this get
off my back i'm out of breath
[Music]
and if he was here we're pretty sure
we'd know what he'd say
[Laughter]
burgers
and private he's the father now they cut
you with something that was in front of
a live audience at some point right
because they wanted to seem like you
know people care my father
my hero joe biden he couldn't sell out
the back room at michael's
[Applause]
what the craft store it's over cut to
black oh
oh my gosh black people in there got it
that's a different piece of black cut
the book
would have been this what if in this
montage there was just a slo-mo of
just just
and they cut right before that which by
the way if you think of being vulgar
people who don't know cardi that's the
that's the person he chose to give the
scoop to yeah it's the number one song
in the world that's the number one song
in the world
top 100 number one
well kids drive the music industry yeah
and they're all done yeah
yeah apparently kids apparently it's
very different from my childhood
at that point we were still in the
creepy crawlers and stretch armstrong
and those arms like that they stick with
the wall you throw them
i thought it was naughty because like i
listened to that song naked on the spice
girls b
side of the cassette oh my gosh the
specials are singing about being naked
yeah
and then on the album cover you can see
they're like midriff you can see them
yeah you can see their mid-drip closure
then it was like salt and pepper that
was too much where they push it push it
good push it real good now it's just
like you know it's just like
i cut my ass off when i came out of my
body
that's not even an exaggeration there's
an instagram but i can't even show it an
instagram video
you're obsessed with this song don't
make us bring up the lyrics this is she
has like
200 million followers that's why he
reached out to her
and then she's like yeah when you click
again for people there
if your kids are in the room sorry this
is what's actually but you know what
they've already heard the songs like yo
when you clean your [ __ ]
you got to go in but i just came out of
the boiler room look at my pants
labyrinth's nails
i cut my [ __ ] y'all gotta be careful
not to cut you she's talking about that
i know she has problems wiping her ass
the damn nails she got
gotta treat your ass all right like you
in church
family i mean it's instructional and
family
i thought democrats hated family yeah
generally they're struggling you see
unless you're
comes with there lives matter yeah they
only hate it when it's
cleaning boilers black families that's
true
they lose a voting base right
dad went up to joey in our bedroom
and saying joey you got to be why do i
care
for the first time for first time saw
the heavy burden on a father
and it was a lesson he would never
forget
the job is a lot more than a paycheck is
about
dignity
[Music]
[Laughter]
joe biden was handled the task
willingness to make adjustments and
accommodations to bring people
on board when the law finally passed his
conscience
flexible when is he supposed to actually
speak because we have this whole segment
with manny
every day i think i think they're just
going to be like oh we ran out of yeah
ran out of time
we've only done one one minute
commercial break we have like all these
commercial breaks we have all these
let's get them in get them in yeah
you're supposed to be speaking now the
biden is supposed to be well maybe right
now
let's wait for biden then see what
happens and then you know what if he's
so bad then you guys can vote
vote send and we'll have two cute maddie
bring up the uh the overlays the votes
in the chat who are watching at the
blaze
if you want a truth according to smooth
manny segment or to hear biden finish
his speech
and our commentary yeah it allows that
child to become an object of ridicule
when his teacher mimicked him and joe
ran home from school
his mother and they're really pulling
and dragging this out are they going to
try and create a whole back backstory
with a stutter now
is this what they're gonna try and do
because that's what they did back when
he was a kid and he had a stutter
which is really inappropriate to mock
him about
you saw that kid in the pink shirt with
the whale logo right he stuttered too
if you mock one stutterer and joe biden
you're mocking that kid who stutters
some letters are harder than others
yeah they just try to explain his weird
behavior girl stand in front of the
mirror
making a key for it practice
she make me look her in the eye look at
me
remember joey you're the smartest boy in
that class
she loves you joe sorry joey
deal with stuttering yep there it is
there it is
they're doing it this is a new thing
have they ever talked about yeah we got
a little bit we gotta look at him
i've never heard about this before and
by the way i still
yeah i still have yet to hear him
stutter at all right yes i hear him i
hear him say
functionally [ __ ] thing why don't
you want a pool full of black kids
because joe biden didn't want them to
swim he voted against that [ __ ] don't
you lie
i like kids sitting on my left yeah if
you look closely there's blacks in the
if you look closely it's biden with a
thing of clorox
jesus christ i quit the law firm and
asked for a job to become a public
defender is this a no pick
how many black men did he get locked up
he's a public defender well yeah just by
being shitty yeah
yeah you know what's funny that's like i
i i wanted to leave my law firm where
there's accountability
incentives and uh a private enterprise
and i wanted to suckle at the government
where it doesn't really matter if i have
an entirely losing
record well there it is the first one
nobody wouldn't hire him
screw it i'd just be a public defender
let's see if in any of these
archive footage videos if there's him
stuttering i've never seen him stutter
go ahead yeah i ran the google trends on
this so
you can see that it literally was just a
couple of months ago that that it became
a thing
the stuttering this guy was the vice
president to unite he ran for president
what four times
talking about a guy whose campaign was
was riddled with scandal back in the 80s
then was forced to shut down
and it never came up that he had a
stutter until he walked out like he
drank a bucket of salt water and did an
interview with cardi b
and couldn't find his way like really
we're this is what they're doing at the
stutter
this is all it is it's it's you know
what this is what happens
when you don't really have you have an
old white guy
who really when your whole campaign
right your whole strategy the dnc has
been
victimhood has been victim status right
you need to have a victim card all right
okay we got a black look when kamala
harris she first won her seat they're
like oh you know at first bla
first indian and i'm like okay first
black vp they go all right
pete buttgay gay guy all right cory
booker gay guy and then they go with uh
with
joe biden like what do we got i don't
know i don't know like a stutter
they need something covered they can
shield them from criticism
no we don't dislike you because of your
stutter we dislike you because you were
part of an administration
that saw the middle class shrink barely
outpace inflation
that you supported segregation you say a
bunch of racist stupid crap
and we know that the rest of the world
would be laughing at us and i know you
say that about donald trump but the
truth is donald trump is at least the
kind of craze that keeps people on their
toes
like the kind of guy you don't really
want as a cellmate because you don't
know if you're going to wake up the next
morning
right that's what donald trump at least
he keeps people honest joe biden
would expose us to vulnerabilities that
we haven't even imagined yet
he can't take care he can't take a
debate with donald trump
we're supposed to believe that he's
going to stare stare down
look at those dentures back then they
zoom white in the photograph
laughter sorry yeah because what we
can't have as a president who's capable
and doesn't have any disabilities and is
the you know
consequence of his own actions
how long was fdr in a wheelchair how
ever present
i don't know years yeah can someone
bring that up how long he was in a
wheelchair just
i don't want to misspeak and then talk
about like a campaign or something
you know but do you think like you think
he was rolling out like all right make
sure you tell them about my wheelchair
first
that should be first that should be
first people didn't announce me
they went to the desk and they rebuilt
the desk to cover it up
yeah because he wanted to you know put
together because he wanted to project
strength
and joe biden is making up a condition
that i'm not eating
is really a condition like a a stutter
is a
medical condition that usually involves
more than just a stutter
it's not like you just stutter usually
there's some kind of essential nervous
issue going on there's some kind of a
tick sometimes there's some kind of a
co-morbidity or some kind of a
psychological psychiatric condition it's
not usually just a stutter so in other
words joe biden
what what has come along with the
stutter is it shingles
right did you did you not get your tv
vaccine or something
[Music]
so i'm counting 97 to 1 ratio on bow to
hunter now
um also it's still about 30 to 1 even
showing pictures of joe biden
compared to beau biden i i think beau is
the candidate
from his time to show him in a mask
joe always found a way whatever helps
cover up his stutter
very
and always holding in his heart the
struggles
all right and every family
always fighting to make his country home
it's a very no he didn't what he did
you're talking oh let me let me find
some
i think i have some info here on the uh
on the joe biden
i don't even know i write down these
thoughts and then i heard
that quote of him calling someone a
dog-faced pony soldier
yeah we do have that yeah or the clip of
the guy uh he tells who to stand up
who's actually in a wheelchair
yeah we have a red center push-ups yeah
but nobody's showing that clip for the
uh
and on how about this quote it doesn't
matter whether they were deprived as a
youth it doesn't
talk about black people it doesn't
matter whether or not they're a victim
of society
the end result is they're about to knock
my mother in the head with a lead pot
left us with this wisdom give people
light
and they will find the way give people
light
those are words for our time you got a
light the current predator
don't hide it under a bushel you person
of color
too much anger too much fear too much
division
no [ __ ] joe my word
if you entrust me with the presidency i
will draw on the best of us
not the worst i'll be an ally of the
light
not the darkness did you see the white
i'll be an ally of the whites not the
[ __ ] i don't get it joe
make no mistake united we can
and will overcome this season of
darkness in america
overcome what season of characters
you're talking about the greatest the
country had ever been
until you guys shut businesses down and
started riots
which you still have you have to co
condemn junior
he's talking about black lives matter
the
i accept this nomination for president
of the united states of america of
course you accept it it's all you've
ever wanted to be a democratic candidate
i will be an american president by
definition
yeah you have to be as hard for them as
i did for those who
did vote for me that's the job of a
president
no stuttering represent all of us how
does it happen that a stutter completely
goes away if it's on prompter and you
don't say [ __ ] stuff partition
moment
hey that's not how a stutter works by
the way somebody sabotages the problem
with the calls for hope he's stuttering
all over that little girl
one of many times he uh taped
yeah it doesn't have to be live nothing
else has been live but they've left the
live card damn it joe you can't
say [ __ ] but they were in the pool
his own teleprompter pledged a new deal
in a time of massive unemployment
uncertainty and fear
stricken by a disease stricken by a
virus
fdr insisted that he would recover and
prevail and he believed america could as
well
and he how did he get that wrong if that
was written in front of him
like he corrected the disease virus like
does that count as a gathering now is he
really smart where he
just has a speech writer who's an idiot
who miswrote and he felt like
thinking correctly do you want to
believe that do we want to believe that
he's just an idiot who misspoke
not just a privileged true at the top
like yourself winning for those
communities
who have known the injustice of a knee
on the neck
oh come on young people have known only
america that's like one guy by the way
all the communities who have known the
injustice of like that's if you're
really
you need to broaden your horizons voting
demographics of america's problems the
neon neck vote
is not that coveted
[Laughter]
you know no generation ever knows what
history will ask of it
all we can ever know is whether we're
ready
when that moment arrives you're not
ready joe
delivered us to one of the most
difficult moments
america's ever faced not that bad four
four but you were saying that officers
in march
because you guys made it so by shutting
down
basically in the entire economy and if
you would have your way
do it until bill gates shows up with his
microchip vaccine
i'm joking but
windows 98 don't trust him with a tv
shot the point is
this is this is they all bill maher
remember he said well i hope we have an
economy crash because you know what
it's a certain point it's more important
because the economy was so
good and it is so good the fundamentals
are still so
sound they need to try and drill it into
people's head
people in into people's heads that
there's uncertainty outside of the
uncertainty that they've created with
their lockdown
people more confident in the economy
than ever i don't trust bill gates
trying to kill a virus and human he
can't even [ __ ] kill him in computers
yet
this will determine what america is
going to look like for a long long time
character is on the ballot
compassion is unavailable decency
science democracy
they're all on the ballot yes on the
rich democracy is a nation
democracy is the ballot it kind of is
would you like to have democracy the
choice could be yes or no
it's in with and under the vet no
rhetoric is needed
just judging oh good then shut the [ __ ]
up
more than 170 000 americans have died
by far the worst performance of any
nation on earth
per capita deaths are actually fantastic
compared to many countries
and they're significantly better in blue
states uh in red states sorry than blue
states if you look at the worst states
as far as covet deaths these are states
that had
severe lockdown measures and they had
and by the way
almost synonymous with horrible nursing
home policies because it'd be a surprise
surprise
blue state's huge bloated bureaucratic
government is inept
right so blue states have done
significantly worse as far as deaths
per thousand deaths per million deaths
per capita but they've also done
unbelievably worse as it relates to the
unemployment rates and economies if you
look at the
certain areas of new york of new york
right now 40 unemployment
you can't find that in any red i'm sure
that you can find them somewhere in some
hills with some people who you know the
hills have eyes or something
but the point is we're talking about a
major state in a major city okay
so let's just we're doing worse no and
by the way this is something too that
cnn lied about i think chris cuomo i
don't even know if we have a clip where
he said wow why is it that we're uh
we're actually our economy is shrinking
by 32 percent
and germany is only 11 no dummy
germany's economy is actually shrunken
more than the united states it's that we
use an annualized rate so our rate was
something like 10 point something
percent
while germany that had more lockdowns
and i believe
less deaths per capita i'm not entirely
sure had an 11 percent shrinking of the
economy so the
how does cnn not know but that's not
what the prompter said
come
because joe's making it up right now i'm
surprised he's going this long takes no
responsibility
blames others they stubbed me they
stopped smelling salt up his nose
it's practically a marathon for the guy
yeah you know like with hillary clinton
they had to stab her with a diazepam pam
like a guy from
310 to yuma with him have to do it with
just amphetamines like he's fighting in
pride
i see a different american you don't see
[ __ ]
i said too many eye lifts it's an
american we can rebuild together
as president the first
but if you die the virus dies with you
you ate my bird until we deal with this
virus
drink the tragedy of where we are today
how do you deal with it have you noticed
this
nothing nothing concrete until we deal
with this virus
can we go to his website can someone
bring up some joe biden policy
anything how's it going to deal with the
virus all i've heard any place he said
he would double
he would force private companies to
double test it virus is going to
disappear
he keeps waiting for a miracle by the
way isn't it interesting that they're
going to force
private companies to double testing but
they're not going to force private
delivery services to speed up
ballot voting because they want the most
incompetent [ __ ] they can possibly
have
handling our mailing votes like you know
what hey we really want mailing votes
let's enlist the amazon brine fans let's
go to fedex like nah nah the only one
who can handle a job
this important is the 13 years losing
money running
usps um so
biden's policy on his website is that he
wants to strengthen
um the federal government and
specifically okay the executive i like
strong you have a decisive public health
response
as well as a decisive economic response
and yet in every moment in every turn
in the last six months has said trump
can't and shouldn't do anything or
direct anything
keep in mind he said that donald trump
was xenophobic because of the travel ban
and he said it was mass hysteria but it
says decisive response
what's a decisive response that's like
when people talk about their journey on
tantric
yoga right they're like oh and it is all
about being present
and your body is entirely releasing
energy and it's about being one with
what are you talking about you're saying
nothing you look into each other's eyes
and
pants what is he saying what is it
what's that does he say
is this whatever the decisive policy is
or just i want to have a decisive policy
it's talking a whole bunch of nothing
to protect one another in short
we'll do what we should have done from
the very beginning and what is that
our current president has failed nothing
what in his most
basic duty to the nation he's failed to
protect us
he's failed to protect america what do
you mean no major wars
[ __ ] americans versus more drone
strikes than civilians
uh anyone what the [ __ ] is he talking
about
he hasn't protected us up until up until
your voting base rioted we also had
a record low crime
we can rebuild it together definitely a
bunch of progressives burning up
i understand how hard it is to have any
hope right now
what summer night this is the problem
with the left because they only have
hope in people right some
some deity joe biden's gonna it's just
really tough to do when you had that
hope and a charismatic person like
barack obama who was new who people
thought had good ideas even though they
had the wall pulled over their eyes
but when you have to hope for some
transcendent political figure to save
you
and instead you get joe biden so that's
why it's hard right now because they
don't believe
in self-reliance right the left i mean
you guys know about this you were
talking about when you used to be
liberals they believe that the deck is
stacked against them
and it needs to be someone changing the
system and the person changing the
system who's going to fix all the
problems is the guy who has
suckled at the dollars of the system
for 40 years yeah all liberals think the
government should give you the
american dream hold on guys they zoomed
in they zoomed in seriously
they're serious it's god's children i
mean he made a dookie in his head
in our lives
he's just swinging his head
[ __ ] you joe stop whisping at me man
that's what angers you most about
tonight this motherfucker's getting all
[ __ ] whispering
though you know my dad was an honorable
decent man not you though his dad was an
honorable
yeah but he always got back up ah he
worked i'd like to meet that guy
that sounds like a better guy that's
like for our family he used to say joey
i don't expect the government to solve
my problems but i sure in hell expect
them to understand them
what the [ __ ] does that mean
it sounds like you're [ __ ] democrat
you're brain dead
no boys that's okay you can use potty
mouth just stay away from these things i
fell for this [ __ ] for years
i was motivated
i was so lost man
it's a personal attack dignity respect
and community
together we can and will rebuild our
economy
and when we do we'll not only build back
we'll build that
better but like you did under eight
years of obama
a thousand year pay increase under about
eight years
five thousand and like two and a half
support claims
to every community with five million new
manufacturing and technology jobs
i'll go on the record and say this if
you out there anyone watching if you
believe that we had a better economy if
you would prefer the economy that
existed
under barack obama at any point than
donald trump
at any point uh you're a succubus who is
providing nothing of value to society
i mean anyone who is working for a
living anyone who is paying taxes
anyone who is actually paying into the
system cannot
logically cannot objectively say that
this economy was better under barack
obama or
even in the same league you can say that
he liked peeing on russian prostitutes
on
on the formica table even though there's
no evidence you can say you wish that
they got him on the russia collusion
even though there's no evidence
you can say that he's mean you can say
that he tweets too much you can say that
he's mcdonald's and he drinks diet coke
and maybe he's
you can say all those things but you
cannot objectively say
if you are anything other than a
non-contributing
[ __ ] bag the economy is not better under
donald trump for you
and your family you can raise a child
you know what they're going to do
i don't believe you you think it'll call
you
as soon as you finish saying that you're
such a racist i know
i know he's no biden
he's still going man this is amazing
it's not only a crisis
it's an enormous opportunity
an opportunity for america to lead the
world and clean no no that's that
by the way that was a friday and slip
yeah don't let any you know don't let
any uh crisis go to waste like
this isn't only a crisis that we created
it's an enormous opportunity we hoped
yeah you know who told him that his
friends in the chinese government
yeah after we burned down all the
buildings and businesses
we'll build it back up i really i
thought he was talking about climate
change i think he actually was i think
it's like nobody cares why they keep
talking about this clean energy [ __ ]
like everything's gonna be solar in
windmills
why couldn't it i'm not looking to
punish anything it's going to be some
crappy enemies
the damn windmills stop working now the
wind stopped blowing
we're sleeping outside another bird man
took it down and for our seniors someone
get don quixote
social security is a settle for a
consultation
a sacred promise made they paid for
the current president is threatening to
break that promise
he's proposing to eliminate a tax that
pays for almost
half the social security without any way
of making up for that lost revenue
uh yeah it's called people having more
money and spending it
dumbass if you actually look at the tax
revenues it's remarkably similar
which again i'm not going to say that
tax revenues are higher under donald
trump i'm sure reg can probably find
this i think they were
slightly less but when you consider how
much less people are paying in
income taxes you understand why the
laugher curve exists you understand that
you can only tax people so much
did you did you guys hear when it was uh
it was a cuomo in new york
cuomo new york was saying i'm getting on
the phone with no no we can't have a
wealth tax
i'm getting on the phone with
billionaires offering to make them
dinner because
don't you understand these billionaires
are the most mobile people in the world
and they're already taxed at the highest
rates we can't screw new york city even
more and i thought it was a babylon b
article turns out cuomo said that [ __ ]
no no no the revenue is about pretty
much the same because people have more
money and they spend
it they put it into the economy these
are people who do not understand
economics whatsoever and more
importantly they don't want you to
understand economics and let's just
say let's say that tax revenue let's say
it was
2 trillion less let's say it was 2
trillion less under under donald trump
than barack i'm just throwing out a
credit it still wouldn't make a debt
and it's not it's not yeah i think reg
has those those numbers it was
i think it was slightly less when you
account for inflation the revenues under
donald trump and barack obama
when you take into account that people
are paying way
less and there's usually a rubber band
effect by the way when that happens when
you cut taxes and people pay less
businesses hire more i can tell you this
we hired two more people
here at loud with crowder because of the
small business tax relief
because of the because of the change in
taxes we invested we could bet more on
ourselves and hire more people
yeah so in 2018 the federal revenues
actually went up a little bit
oh really so yeah they went up some
and then i think they dropped a little
bit in the following year so yeah
not a huge difference so they went up
and they went down a little bit
only people have a lot more in their
account because they're paying less in
taxes and have an average salary
increase of five thousand dollars
ha ha well that seems like a bargain
let's see what dr shittiest pants has to
say
she's an educator a mom a military mom
an unstoppable force what are you
talking about if she puts her mind to it
himself just get out of the way she's
going to get it
transgender she was a great second lady
and i know she'll make a great first
lady for this nation
she loves this country so much
and i'll always have the strength that
can only come from family
and why don't you talk about family joe
why don't you talk at these riots and
protests and the violence
outbreaks and talk about how the single
greatest indicator we have as to whether
a child will end up having a family of
his own
as to whether he'll graduate high school
go to college commit crimes have
behavioral disorders
uh have an abortion commit a violent
crime commit a felony
all the single greatest indicator we
have the single
most reliable predictor is not how much
money is being spent in their public
school
is not how many people do we have in the
village to raise a child
it's not the federal budget it's do they
have a mommy and daddy and are they
still
in the house together why don't you go
out and talk about that if you're saying
you can only draw on strength
that comes from a family how about you
change the welfare laws that encourage
baby mamas
how about that if you can
if if we if they believe that taxes are
so effective
at curbing or manipulating behavior and
they believe that right because they
want to tax
gas and energy hopefully when you see
the gas is so expensive you'll start
using
less in your car they want to tax big
gulps why
because they think that if you see how
expensive they are because the tax that
you're paying on big gulps you're no
longer going to purchase big gumps they
want to put
astronomical taxes on cigarettes why
because they believe that'll curb your
behavior
if they decide to put taxes on
cigarettes so you'll do it less yet for
some reason
they still incentivize single-parent
households
in our in in our current social safety
nets and welfare programs
they know that taxes can affect behavior
they use it
unconstitutionally all the time and they
dis-incentivize starting a business
yes starting a business starting a
family those yeah those are bad things
they also dis-incentivize
[Applause]
close your income remember what you saw
on television no never with joe around
never close your eyes come on close your
eyes and take a sniff
spewing the same same anti-semitic bile
hurt across europe in the thirties
what what does he talk what remember
nazism yeah
between those spreading hate and those
with the courage to stand against it
really what'd you guys do for israel you
and bucky obama buddy
what'd you do huh what went down with a
ram why don't you tell us how you gave
it to him
they ain't doing [ __ ] about these damn
black lives matter beating up white
people either right
oh they don't care call to action they
have cardi b out there with a megaphone
that's lovely cause my father taught us
that silence was complicity if joe's
father's alive he'll [ __ ] slap him
you would hope boy at the time
but you know i mean we don't know
dementia could run in the family you may
not recognize him
and we are you know
man i thought he was done
there was something there someone who
was like did he just compare trump to
nazis
that's what it sounded like gianna floyd
he's going to cry for her daddy george
floyd it's laid to rest
then they exploit everything that's bad
that's happening everything i'll never
forget
when i leaned down to speak to her
she looked in my eyes and she said i
quote daddy
changed the world daddy
changed the world wow
deep into my heart that's crazy maybe
george floyd murder
you know what though i will and this is
this is why people say why does it
matter this is why it matters because
you know what
that girl it's really sad that she's
gonna grow up without a dad because
he made horrible decisions and
unfortunately there was bad training at
the police department as far as i'm as
far as i'm concerned when you watch the
whole tape
that cop did zero wrong outside of using
the techniques that were taught to that
police department you can find the flyer
right now where they show people with
knees on next which is horrible that's
horrible trending
there was no malice there was no racism
but you know what's really sad about
that
is that no one sees the irony that thank
god that that little girl
floyd's girl was not the girl who was at
the house of the lady who george floyd
mugged and robbed at gunpoint while his
buddies pistol whipped her she had a
one-year-old in the house with her
he changed the world let's be honest
about what it is if you want to bring up
every single flaw that donald trump has
despite the fact that as a president
he's done a damn good job well how about
you how about you talk about the fact
that this guy who changed the world
was a serial violent felon and by the
way wasn't spending much time
with that girl that girl could have used
a dad instead of a mugger
yeah that's just too much common sense
there steve
and it you know it's one of those things
two wrongs don't make a right
but there's wrong and there's an
accident and if you go and watch the
[ __ ] you guys watch the full george
floyd tape
and you understand that that was the
technique i don't know why it was taught
to members of the police department that
cop didn't do anything wrong
policy and they called the ambulance
twice and they gave him every
opportunity to uh get in the car yeah
they not only gave me up he said we'll
stay with you we'll roll down the window
and turn on the air
and this guy is out he just talked about
fermenting hate
you're asking for a lynch mob to go to
that cop's house who was compassionate
empathetic
and barely used any naughty words yeah i
find it weird that he's
he's claiming he's got claustrophobia
but he's he's a he was a big man he was
in a front seated car
it wasn't very much space then all of a
sudden when he's getting arrested oh i
got claustrophobia
you know he has he has incarcerated yeah
he's getting that he's getting out of an
old metro geo
and he has not he has no qualms with it
then all of a sudden they want to put
him in the back of a suburb he's like ah
i can't i'm claustrophobic i was talking
to a cop at the airport about that whole
incident
people like um george floyd the the
drugs he had in his system
a lot of them they find him in jail dead
oh all the time yeah
he had lethal amounts which are about
fentanyl and methamphetamine yeah and he
had just had kobe
yeah that dude had everything and listen
is it it's absolutely sad that somebody
died who didn't need to die and then
yeah exactly yeah but we also don't need
it we don't need to
we don't need to layer tragedy on top of
tragedy and now ruin their didn't we
learn
anything from ruining darren wilson's
life with mike brown yeah yeah
that poor guy never gets his life back
he asked to serve
the black community that's why he was in
ferguson george floyd caused the death
it was a heart attack right he had heart
disease too right you know they they're
claiming that it was that was the white
uh the white medical examination they're
hiring their own third party and that uh
it shows that it was clearly the cops
knee and his neck so
who knows he she he says she says what
joe's getting angry now oh is he he's
got his angry furrow brow
ah oh thank god it's over
look at him he said he's playing gospel
music he's like can i walk away now
look at his wife come on hold him by the
shoulder
they're all laughing laughing clap now
yeah
yeah
it's over
[Applause]
what are you waving at and by the way
they didn't have to
use kamala they could have easily done
this in front of a lot laughing at
herself
like they're not really clapping are
they look at us
this is all pre-recorded where are their
masks oh my
that okay i will say this we've been a
lot of live streams in our day and then
it's you know you never know because it
can be a hit or miss uh
as far as what there is nothing to
factor there was nothing it was the fact
that there was
nothing it was clips of you know my
daddy uh he likes briars
and he is hooked on phonics
oh my god look at that african-american
female she's a sellout
she married a white man she is white huh
yeah she's such a sellout
that's that's how we're supposed to view
things now everything's through the
prism of race
i was just saying we have some costumes
oh we have some costumes
ladies costumes sorry smooth manny we'll
have to do your uh
cube of saturn another day i was looking
forward to that we have to learn that
we'll do it we'll do it we have some
other bits that we'll get to i'm sorry i
just got so mad with the [ __ ]
that's all good he's shooting with the
landslide right trump
i hope so i mean this country should not
be this dumb
this will it's not dumb it's people i
will say this human beings are selfish
are naturally selfish and unfortunately
um they also have short memory so it
doesn't mean that people are dumb but
when you've told them that the
the deck is tacked against them that the
system is broken and then you've
proactively broken the system
as they've done right now with the kovid
and supporting
the riots you know over close to a
billion dollars in property damage 900
officer casualties 14 000 arrests
and you've tried to put americans in a
state of fear and then promise them
a handout i think unfortunately that is
a recipe to gain some votes not because
they're good it's because people are
inherently selfish
and really it comes down to
conservatives are inherent everyone is
inherently selfish
and then you combine selfishness with
what is morally
uh allowable what is morally permissible
in the idea of not intervening in
someone else's life
along with logic because even if you're
selfish you understand that um
put it this way if the democrats are the
party of the poor they need
more americans at least a plurality of
americans to stay poor
if republicans are the party of the rich
they need at least
half the country to be or at least think
that they can be rich
so one has to be hopeful and one has to
be
well everything's stacked against you
i'm gonna be your your savior until the
next democrat comes on down
listen to the difference between they
can say donald trump is mean
sure they can say that donald trump is
immature bombastic absolutely
but donald trump's message is absolutely
one
of hope and optimism and hey and he's
not saying we can get back to people say
he wants to say we can get back to the
50s no he's saying we can get back to
january which was country the greatest
seen
until everyone in the media and the left
said it was mass hysteria when i tried
to put in a travel ban
and now they're shutting down the
economy there's a huge huge difference
when you look at zero information zero
policy proposals from
joe biden and nothing but negativity
but nihilism and the deck is stacked
against you uh but the good news is
the guy who's been in government for 40
years and done nothing will
fix it in four he'll fix it this time
he'll fix it this time
all right let's go to the costume
winners
all right we have uh yeah we have uh
holland oates oh
no it's nice me and the husband is that
oh is that a i can't see that's a
that's a lady doing oh good for her hold
on
with the mustache yes that's not bad at
all i respect that
miracle on ice yeah yep oh that's a good
one right there i like that
she's also outside which means and then
we have the wedding
for a really crappy night
of people speaking on skype look what
got the mask on now
yeah they just that's so fun it's like
the ufc
[Laughter]
they're standing alone on a stage
husband and wife
wearing masks this is a democratic party
right now
it is all about i mean they're
charlatans they're absolutely true
they're putting masks on there is no
possible way they could be
that girl they don't even
and she's half inside her car gosh joe
biden is just on an outdoor stage
oh this is the thing they don't believe
any of this [ __ ]
they really don't yeah they really don't
do you really think that these people
are afraid for their life and that's why
they're wearing a mask do you think
that's why he looks like reptile from
mortal kombat
he does no it's because right now he's
like oh photo op they're gonna be taking
the picture for tomorrow's paper so i
better make sure i put my mask on
because it was a pre-tape before
yeah i mean i don't even i don't even
think he just gave that speech look his
head i don't think i think he
yeah this is in vegas i think where is
this right now is this in vegas
no it says wilmington delaware it's in
wilmington where'd you get vegas from
yeah
you're drunk go home all right
again the promo code i think it's uh
it's still up here for the next
uh well 24 hours from the start of the
stream 20
off if you enter in crowder dnc stream
at lotterycrowder.com
and on top of that we have to make sure
to thank the people who are sticking by
us
during all of this during the height of
cancel culture yeah black rifle coffee
and oh that's right you can go ahead the
boys got it over there right between
them
yeah if you return the coffee grab the
coffee yeah if you're republican
and you consider you ain't drinking
black rifle coffee then you ain't
conservative
[Laughter]
seriously yeah i mean if you're gonna
support a business
yeah these guys are ex-veterans i know
them person these are some good guys
and besides there's some damn good
coffee yeah
yeah let's be honest they don't drink
coffee they're more red bull guys but
well i like a good couple it's good do
you yeah yeah i drink coffee do you
drink coffee
how do you drink it in a cup of milk
[Laughter]
this is good look at that black
riflecoffee.com
crowder and i don't know do they still
need to enter the promo code crowd or
just go to the crowd
boom 20 off your first order and i will
say i'm a huge coffee snob and by the
way to chill son and who just got into
coffee we're going to be sending you a
bag pretty soon because he finally sent
me some of those
healthy cereal boxes um listen it's one
of those things
it's a gimme if you drink coffee
it's it's unfortunately one of the great
hazards that you have to navigate in the
grocery aisle that uh that
almost all coffee companies and
certainly they hate everything you stand
for if you look into what starbucks and
a lot of these companies
right black rifle there's better coffee
it's fresh roasted
yeah it's yeah it's veteran owned and
they they they do a lot for veteran
cause and that's great but it is
better coffee and at the very let's say
it wasn't owned by veterans
let's say it just it was owned by
non-assholes
who didn't hate everything you stand for
and it is wouldn't that still be enough
they're going to be drinking that coffee
every morning might as well be better
coffee that's not owned by people who
want to destroy the very fabric of
westeros
that's it louder was crowded oh sorry
not not with it blackriflecoffee.com
crowder we should also have a ladder
with crowder.com black rifle coffee
yeah yeah even guys store in san antonio
they do yeah great coffee you can go buy
actually evan at black rifle sent me
that wonderful it was like a five
thousand dollar
special machine from the san antonio
shop and then
usps played kickball with it
you had where it was totally broken and
it was going to cost me 2 400
to repair hey that's an institution
stephen you can't talk about that man
yeah yeah it was poking out of the box
they should be in charge
actually the metal frame was poking out
of the box you think someone there were
like oh
they were checking it for defects oh
yeah but we want them to handle the
election of the free world did you see
your name stephen crud on it
uh i don't think so i don't have
anything delivered to my name steven
crowd i hate this [ __ ]
well it was ruined so i do know about
the store in san antonio um they still
owe me an espresso machine uh no they
don't actually it's a post office
i have so much that i could get into
with the post office hey yeah well you
know what that is nice to see
that they are waving a flag instead of
burning a car
so that's progress that is progress
stephen
i'm saying that that democrats burn cars
and police precincts
what was i not clear look here's the
thing that's a nice everyone where
everyone who's truly waving a flag out
in that parking lot right now
should be voting they're really good at
making them look like they're like
very diverse no i think they're pretty
much making them look black with two
white people in the middle
that's what they're doing it's like
they're making them look like a malamar
that's nice that works all right uh
thank you everybody we appreciate you
being with us we had so many other
things that we were going to get to
uh it was just so much crap tonight oh
he's got his mask off and we have the
hodge twins
he's got to look at that put your mask
on what changed
what's he gonna die now that he pulled
his mask off what changed that you can
pull your mask off there
you felt the urge to put it on he just
took and now he's putting it back
now she says put your mask on you damn
nitwit
that lost in the election why didn't you
pull it off did a six-year-old walk by
that's not a lot of people wait i'm
waiting for all the memes to come out
because every single one i see is like
oh you see these people going in a place
and they're wearing it on their face so
they
gotta hang it off and hey your
candidate's doing it yeah awkward
she's hoping to rape his hand there he
goes there he goes
yeah he took it off to yell particles
all right so you heard it here we have
the hodge twins conservative
twins i think they might be here uh for
some stuff next week and certainly some
content that we have going with them
uh it's conservative twins on youtube
youtube
and facebook is the hodge twins i always
love having here half asiation lawyer
bill richmond quarterblack garrett audio
way
too cute maddie thank you so much the
promo code is crowder dnc stream for 20
off at loudouscredit.com club and please
that's the only thing that allows us to
do this anyway we'll be doing special
streams for every event town hall
debates if they ever actually happen um
and i think we learned a lot tonight
is you really do have a choice to make
you have a choice to make between
the greatest economy the united states
has ever seen no major wars
uh economic growth like we couldn't
possibly imagine
a world that's actually fearfully
respectful of us
or be a [ __ ] chaos
[Laughter]
joe biden and cardi b we'll see you on
[Music]
monday
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
you will be the greatest
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
you